to know law so I would like to go ahead
and have the attendance uh called Madame
clerk representative
cor
roomes
[Music]
representative you have
Ford representative L
here representative sod here
representative
Miler calling from uh I'm here calling
from uh kukuk New Hampshire and I'm in
the room by myself my wife may be
walking through period
periodically thank you representative
luno reporting from
Hopkinson representative Shaw I'm here
representative Cornell I see you
I'm here home
alone representative
Tanner um I'm here with my wife who's
working represent Ellison uh I'm here
home alone in
conquer representative Mullen I am here
alone representative
Le and present I am in Jaffrey New
Hampshire and I am home alone
representative
Woodcock I am here in Senate col New
Hampshire my wife will be in and out
periodically and I'm gonna
representative
Andress home alone in
Salsbury and representative
Ford Home Alone
Chester and representative L here I'm
L
okay we do have a quorum and with that
me okay thank you uh so with that we're
going to move forward with our docket
for today and open up the hearing on our
first bill which is HB 432 this is an
act relative to the offenses that
prevent employment in a
school uh representative Mullen I
believe you are the prime sponsor of
that bill are you ready
to I am ready to go Mr chair thank you
thank thank you for recognizing me for
the record I'm representative Su Mullen
I represent hilsboro County district 7
the town of
Bedford uh this morning you have before
you House Bill
432 which looks to uh include human
trafficking on uh to be added to what we
currently know as the list of criminal
offenses that
prevent employment in schools in New
Hampshire um prior to the hearing I
provided members with a copy of that uh
18913 section five list of current
offenses that prevent employment in
schools in New Hampshire and also a copy
of 637 which is the definition of human
trafficking from the criminal
code 432 was born uh during the last
legislative session uh
in a two-part fashion first uh we were
became aware in discussing other related
crimes that are included in section five
that human trafficking was not on that
list and given the fact that attention
was being drawn to human trafficking by
both uh the international crimes against
children task force Homeland Security
Police Chiefs across New Hampshire the
Department of Education uh through
attorney Diana Fenton actually uh
requested that human trafficking be
added to to this
list originally the bill also had a
provision uh for outof State offenses
that were similar in nature that could
be considered Equitable to the section
five offenses but subsequent to
submitting the bill
uh I also made sure that each of you had
a copy of the amendment to this bill
which is
15h and what 001 15h does is strike the
language from the bill that says
reasonably equivalent offenses uh in an
outof State jurisdiction would also uh
be eligible for preventing
employment that Amendment uh again was
uh the request of the Department of
Education who upon further consideration
decided that there was so much variation
particularly among the states around our
border that we would actually muddy the
waters uh and perhaps prevent things
from moving along in terms of human
trafficking uh sort of counter to what
the original intent of the bill was so
as the bill stands amended and that is
what I'm hoping uh we will move forward
with
today House Bill 432 simply adds human
trafficking to the list of offenses that
prevents employment in schools in New
Hampshire uh I believe attorney Fenton
is also with us this morning in some
form or another and would be available
to answer any questions that anybody
would have that I'm not able to answer
but I am uh happy to take questions as
the members see fit this
morning thank you representative Mullen
are there any questions for
representative
Mullen uh does is the motion on the
floor need to be seconded for the
amendment uh no it we don't have an
we're still in the in the process of
taking testimony uh we won't be acting
on any Amendment until we have the all
the testimony
submitted
not seeing any yes representative
cordelli thank you Mr chairman um
representative Mullen uh just for anyone
who might not have uh the amendment in
front of them um if you were looking at
the original Bill am I correct and that
it's online and five and
sixed print is the uh section that has
been removed in the amendment yes you
are absolutely correct representative
cordelli
further
questions thank you very much
representative Mullen uh we will move
down we have a total of 10 people that
signed that I have right here in front
of me that have signed in uh to uh give
input on this bill of which uh there are
two that actually want to testify so
I'll call the next person forward which
is di Fenton from the Department of
us I am good morning good morning
Diana it's nice to see everyone I think
I can still say that in this new world
of Zoom um thank you for having me
honorable members of the committee I my
name is Diana Fenton I'm an attorney
with the Department of Education I want
to thank representative Mullen for
bringing this bill forward this bill is
fairly straightforward by way of
relevant background um RSA
18913a uh in the education law book has
a list of
offenses that would prohibit individuals
from serving as an educator um in the
state of New Hampshire and I believe
representative Mullen has provided you
with that list if you look at it in the
statute book uh RSA
18913a they just list them by the
criminal offenses by number and that
confuses the heck out of me and it's my
job as a lawyer to know those offenses
so I created a cheat sheet and I hope
you find it as helpful as I find it um
you can see in that list of offenses
they're pretty egregious offenses
capital murder child pornography
kidnapping um endangering the welfare of
a child anything child related and we
believe that human trafficking is
appropriate to add to this list human
trafficking has always been an offense
um however it was
recently codified in the criminal code I
think in in 2009 which explains why it
wasn't on the original list um in
18913a I'm happy to take any questions
you have I also believe there are people
uh representatives from the Department
of Health and Human Services that can
speak more eloquently than myself um to
the offense of human trafficking and
what other steps DHHS is taking in
recognition of the serious offense um
being part of our
state thank you very much Miss Benton uh
are there any questions from the
committee uh of attorney
Fenton Mr
chair who up
luno represent luno there you
are thanks very much Mr chair and uh and
um and great to have you here um Miss
Venton unfortunately we can't see you
but U but it's it's great it is great to
hear your voice and um and uh just a
just a question as it relates to the the
statute uh over and above the um uh the
list of um of criminal activity that
you've put in that in that memo is it
true that um that school administrators
or or School boards can um Can can
disqualify somebody for um for any other
misdemeanors or felonies that they see
fit
yes you are correct so the list that's
contained in RSA
18913a
is consistent across the board if you
will it's applicable to every school
district it's saying that as a state we
as a state do not want individuals with
these types of offenses to serve as
teachers but you are correct
representative luno that each individual
District can make a choice to add to
that list so if you um you know the way
my mind works RSA
18913a is similar to the Federal
Constitution it is the floor of
protection um districts individual
districts are like the state
constitution they can be more protective
but not less what the what the
department is seeking is really kind of
a statement to say across the state we
don't want this offense of human
trafficking to be in our schools we want
that to be consistent with uh throughout
the state we don't want that to be
discretionary thank you for the question
no thank you very much Miss Venton are
there any other questions from the
committee not seeing any hands up and
not hearing in this room um this
concludes the uh folks that actually
want to testify in this bill we had uh
people that uh wanted to testify or
present information of those 10
two spoke the other eight uh chose not
to and of of those um 10 we have one two
three four five in support one neutral
which would be our technical support
from the Department of Education and we
had uh three others that were
opposed so at this point in time I will
close this hearing and
and any objections to that no so this
hearing is now closed and we will then
we have um according to this clock here
about 14 minutes I'd like to move into
executive session on this particular
bill
and we will is there any opposition
Desiring okay I would uh um I'm going to
take up the amendment
first um so uh representative Mullen
would you like to please make a motion
on that amendment of yours I would I uh
Mr chair make the motion that amendment
015h to House Bill 432 ought to
pass and representative Allard would you
like to second that motion yes I would
Mr chairman I second the motion so we
have an amendment uh up for discussion
it has been moved by represent Mullen
and second by representative Allard any
discussion from committee
members could I speak to the amendment
for uh one second Mr
chair well we're if if you want to you
can hold off and speak as amended at the
whatever the next motion is ought to
pass as amended okay I I I will I I'll
defer to your judgment okay okay thank
you very much not seeing any further
discussion on this uh amendment I will
ask the clerk to take the
role representative representative glad
I'm sorry I just wanted to make sure
everyone was reminded to turn their
requirement
I I I I think we're set to go um would
the vice chair look to make sure he sees
go ahead
and
visually represent Shaw would you please
go ahead with
the
yes this is representative Ford I'm
trying to find the button for what
you're talking
about de can you help him out start
video I'm not on the bottom should be
you start I have share screen I have
record oh here it is okay
so I do stop video right start well you
yeah you you don't want a red line in
front of
it okay well I got nothing on there
neither one of them is marked I'm sorry
I zoom is indicating that you may not
have a camera connected that's probably
true no I
don't that's on this afternoon shopping
list okay hey Best Buy okay
uh we'll go ahead with the vote here
please representative Shan
representative uh B yes representative
Allard yes representative lakus yes
representative mofet yes representative
Hobson yes representative
Andress you can't vote you can't vote
I'm not able to vote I don't do
video representative for yes well you
can't vote you can't see can't vote you
can't see me sorry representative
leaden Le I'm sorry
yes I'll get it representative sod yes
representative Miler yes representative
luno yes representative shy yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
Ellison yes representative Mullen yes
representative Le yes representative
yes
18 okay 18 to zero the amendment passes
motion
Mr chairman thank you uh I move that
house bill 432 as
amended be submitted or ought to pass
represent Mullen is there a second I
I'll second it okay uh now we have the
bill as amended for discussion uh do you
care to discuss this uh you made the
motion first I know representen is also
asked to speak no I'll get I yield my
time back to you okay thank you I don't
see any hands up here nor on the screen
so we are prepared are you ready to go
forward the I am okay Madame clerk would
you please call the
rle representative cordelli yes
representative B yes representative
Allard yes representative leakas yes
representative Moffett yes
representative Hobson yes uh Andress are
you still blank he can't okay and for
Lon yes representative sod yes
representative Miler yes representative
luno yes representative Shaw yes
representative Cornell yes
representative
Tanner yes representative Ellison yes
representative Mullen yes representative
leay yes representative woodcock yes
representative glad yes 18
Z the motion ought to pass as amended
passes
1820 congratulations
committee first bill first
bill okay is uh uh been asked to be
place this uh item on the consent agenda
by representative B is there any
opposition thank
you okay we're on to be taking about
a six minute break here before we can
bill
to
they're too late now this bill is g no
not this bill another bill we yeah to
late no no we go to the list that you
okay do we do the amendment before we
have motion to to pass on the bill
itself
and then don't take action on that and
then to hear an
amendment a motion pass the way I did it
first take the am so I wrote to him to
clarify
in yes we get the posi motion but we
motion and then the amend I think that
has to
pass
passed
yeah
[Music]
oness
committee okay that's what I thought
okay we're good thank
you right bye bye
I was right yes you were bar that's why
we caught you in that
extra
okay thank
to
to on the front page General right there
in the front go down testify you hit
that and and they'll come up with a
calendar you click on the calendar like
the 26 and all the committies will pop
[Music]
be okay we got to go ahead and start
here
now I'm sorry where' the clerk go
bathroom
good morning again to the committee
members that were out there in uh remote
land and for those that are here we got
to get them out of the hallway back from
the bathroom and get going on here um
what we have here is the next bill is
hb3
304 that's uh committee to study the
Career Technical education funding for
tuition and
transportation we're going to go into
that I am the prime sponsor so I will be
stepping away from the chairmanship here
to present the bill and representative
cordelli Vice chair will act in my stad
following uh my testimony I will come
back run the meeting but I will not be
asking any questions just con conducting
the meeting so with that I'll hand the
cordelli thank you I would like to uh
open the Committee hearing on
hb34 uh establishing a committee to
study the funding of tuition and
transportation for Career Technical
education and I'll call on the uh Prime
sponsor to introduce the bill uh
chairman
lad thank you very much Mr chairman uh
for the record my name is Rick lad I
come from hail New Hampshire uh Grafton
for um I would like to speak to this
bill uh it's a bill that's dear to my
heart uh Career Technical education is
extremely important in our state we in
the state of New Hampshire have a
population of 64,000 kids in our high
schools
of that
64,000 9,000 students are in Career
Technical
education about 14% of our entire High
School population in Career Tech Ed
we've done a lot to help Career Tech Ed
in the last few years we've allowed
concurrent dual enrollment to work in
CTE centers we've taken Career techn
Technical education and opened it up to
students in grades
10 11 and 12 we've also in the city of
Manchester have ninth grade kids
participating in that we've allowed our
instructors in the CTE Center an
alternate pathway where they can uh
receive uh credentialing to instruct in
a CTE Center without having to jump some
of the hurdles that those that are in a
rigor classroom in teaching the Reading
Writing and
arithmetic I'm on the CTE advisory
commission for the state along with
folks from the business industry
Association Along with folks
representing doe repres those small
business and other
legislators for several years we've been
grappling with how we fund tuition and
transportation the recent study
committee on the commission for
Education funding also grappled with
this CTE monies as with special
education Aid the old cat Aid building
Aid um is a categorical grant for
funding it's separate from adequacy
although uh CTE if you look at the what
the indicators are for the delivery of
an adequate education of those
indicators three of which are ones that
deal directly with the number of
students that and the percentage of
students which are participating in CTE
programs and onto skill Pathways which
are going to reinforce our
Workforce so with that I'd like to to
get into a little of the specifics on
this we will have Eric fur worth from
the Department of Education the director
of CTE speaking following myself um we
are we are asking that we set up a
commission a committee to for the
purpose of looking at this more
thoroughly um and understanding that
it's very difficult
for uh CTE centers to function excuse
me the actual Transportation cost for
school districts to send kids to a CTE
Center roughly around $2.6
million they get reimbursed through our
formula approximately $680,000 you can
see there's a huge cost laid down on our
school districts to get kids to the CTE
centers that often times results in
certain districts capping the number of
students which can participate in this
very important skill opportunity and so
it's really the opportunity to acquire
this end of CTE program is not
necessarily available to all students it
based upon in one several instances the
availability of transportation to and
from we also then have the issue of
tuition of the $9 million we uh send or
use for CTE tuition and transportation
after you deduct the the transportation
costs which are at 10 cents a mile which
is a very low figure to be reimbursing
to send a bus from where I live in havil
naire to our CTE Center which is located
in Bradford Vermont there are a number
of CTE centers along the Connecticut
River that service both sides of the
river so there the tuition um amount is
also an area where we need to be looking
at in terms of is the tuition money
going to be available to a district
which has their own CTE Center within
for example if I'm in Plymouth New
Hampshire or Manchester New Hampshire
and we have a CTE centers in both of
those districts they're not going to get
any funding for tuition however if I'm
in holderness New Hampshire just outside
the parameter of Plymouth holderness
will receive tuition money for the
centers the centers are are indeed a h a
a future for our education programming
and we need to really take a careful
look at that uh we were unable to do it
during the commission study um it's time
that we resolve this matter sit down and
figure out where we're going to go with
many of these issues another issue is
that we have 28 CTE of which they get
funding for Capital Improvements one a
year
and by the time you get to that 28th
year the equipment they have is largely
outdated they get support from the
business indust industry Association
various automobile associations and the
culinary arts and you name it they they
provide it and it's something we need to
take a look at so I I request that we
consider this bill move forward with the
concept of having a committee study to
really come back with some of these
answers we need regarding career Technic
[Music]
chairman I will uh relinquish the chair
and turn it back over to uh chairman
lad thank you very much got that without
getting out on my
seat so the next next person I'd like to
invite to testify would be Eric forworth
from the Department of Education Eric
you with us
um point of order Mr chair yes yeah are
you going to be taking
questions pardon me are you going to be
taking I would prefer not to take
questions um to expedite this long I
think that any any question to me is
also G to be be able to be answered by
Eric well um I I think there may be a
question with with regards to
legislative
intent that I think that I think you may
be in the best position to answer go
ahead and ask your question represent
Luna actually um I'm I'm happy to do it
but I um there may be others that
are Mel do you want me to do it yeah
yeah yeah actually Rick not to be
technical here you should not be in the
chair right
now uh represent cordelli should still
be chairing because you're going to be
answering questions as the maker of the
well okay I I don't want to be technical
here but I think the technical okay
repesent cordelli is now chairing this
meeting I'm still sitting in the center
chair my same
chair go ahead I'm
sorry so so I'll I'll I'll I'll take it
thank you very much um um Mr chair I was
just wondering um how this bill will uh
will address um uh how members will be
committee the uh if that's to myself
here the on on the committee uh
membership the members of the committee
shall be as follows so it's stated
within that um seven members of the
House of Representatives appointed by
the Speaker of the House of
Representatives two of whom shall be
members of the standing committee having
jurisdiction over education and two of
whom shall be members of the standing
committee with jurisdiction over the
finance two members of the Senate
appointed by the president of the Senate
so they will be appointed by the speaker
and by the um president of the
Senate uh
followup yes yeah so is it the thank you
very much Mr chair is it the legislative
intent that the appointments will be
proportional to um to party membership
um u in the U in the legislature in the
in the in the
two
Chambers the speaker of the house and
the Senate President have the
opportunity to appoint these members
they will make that decision and I'm
sure that they will make a decision
which AFF Forge both parties to
participate um I was hoping that may
have been done with the commission for
studying funding of Education which were
seven elected officials and there's one
elected Republican I'd like to see that
reversed on this committee so that we
have participation coming in from both
sides well if if I might I'd also say
that the uh that the governor had uh had
an appointment and um and other
appointments were made uh from the from
public members that uh that I don't
believe were all members of the same
party
so I I I would like to just if I may Mr
chair uh this respond that
Career Technical education to all of us
and I I believe I can speak on behalf of
everybody on this education committee we
all believe in CTE programming we all
recognize we have to do something to
improve how we fund
CTE we need to improve so much Capital
Improvement and and for the development
of these and there is a task force
working at the Department of Education
now but but we need to also educate and
inform our public educate and inform
legislators educate and inform schools
uh counselors educate uh leadership
within the school community that CTE is
not what our fathers and grandfathers
once knew it to be CTE is now taking
graphic design computer technology it's
into agricultural aspects it's in
automotive mechanics and Automotive uh
technology it's a huge field as you all
know we cannot wait we need to really do
something uh and move forward with the
idea that CTE programming is a a option
for students to consider we need to get
out of this old channel that you got to
go to a four-year
school this we have too many
opportunities with a two plus two
program we have too many opportunities
where you can come out with skill
certificate and a pathway which will
lead to you lead you towards a job and
productivity in our state and keep folks
here so um I went a little bit beyond on
answering your question uh I cannot tell
you what the speaker would do or the
president but I know the speaker I know
this this speaker would definitely try
to get folks from both sides and the the
president of the Senate has been there
before and all the times I've seen him
Senator Morris
uh put folks on to various committees
he's done it uh trying to get
representative representation from both
sides thank you Mr chair I've got a
question uh yes representative Miler uh
Rick I I don't disagree with anything
you you just have said because this is
an important issue no question about it
but I've been informed that the the
president of the Senate has basically
said that any they will not deal with
any committee or Commission
coming out of this legislative session
have you heard that I mean is that how
does that statement relate to creating
question I would like to say that we
need to move forward with this
legislation we need to inform all folks
that this is important I believe a
committee can function we have a job
that was started in uh the committee
with commission which represent luno
initiated this last year and went
through summer and fall um we need to
continue that we need to with the the
this is also coming out of the Career
Technical education advisory commission
um plus when you have the next person
that's going to speak Eric ask him you
know can we hold off on this any further
we cannot we can't afford it you know
this may not net us exactly what we want
but this will net us the opportunity to
let our public know that we need to move
on this topic and hopefully some good
legislation can come out of this
committee study so your your leg your
your leadership then uh your Republican
leadership has not indicated to you the
issue of commissions or committees come
uh being authorized that that's okay or
is that not okay it's just a procedural
question I'm really asking I'm I'm not
debating the merits of the of the
proposal here because I think I would
support that but I'm just concerned
about how it's going to go forward and
how it's going to be received I will
work work very diligently to work with
the people on both sides of the wall uh
there's some issues that we need to come
together as a group here there's some
issues which are not political issues
this is one of those this is about as
youve said representative Myer many
times our
kids and this one right here is that
that's how we need to persuade all to
get off this political divide and to
work together towards this common end
thank you thank you any further
questions may I uh representative bum
yeah thank you this bill after we pass
it if it gets passed by the house we'll
go to the Senate right and the Senate
can then make the changes they need to
make
correct well that's the that's the I I
can't respond to that I'm not not
running a meeting uh yes yes uh that is
the typical process that we would
follow yes um there no other uh
questions of Representative lad I will
turn the meeting back over to him
thank you very much I'd like to now ask
if Eric is on
the remote here somewhere Eric
forworth uh good morning repad yes thank
you I am
on thank you uh for the record I'm Eric
frow worth and the administrator for the
Bureau of career development at the New
Education and uh thank you I am uh
speaking definitely in favor of the
creation of this commit
uh I believe rep lad uh gave a very good
picture of what our challenges with
regard to tuition and
transportation and uh we have just
completed um an an equitable uh access
study uh through a consultant looking at
uh students ability to access CTE across
New Hampshire and
transportation consistently Rose to the
surface as one of the challenges as to
why students are not uh participating in
CTE at the level that uh which com uh
comparable States uh have participation
in um and although you know
geographically I understand that we are
different than Delaware uh we like to
utilize them as a comparison because of
uh size and scope uh and their access to
a similar amount of Perkins money uh we
have about 15% of our eligible high
school students particip ating in CTE
they have 65% of their eligible students
participating in
CTE uh and so just at that level um
figuring out a way to increase our
transportation and tuition availability
for our students would open the door for
a larger much larger percentage of
students to participate uh and so rather
than you know throwing numbers and
statistic at you I would be happy to to
open up to questions anyone might have
about where the benefit of this
committee uh where I see the benefit of
this committee would
be are there any questions from members
committee I don't yes which represent
Woodside thank you represent lad
uh Mr rorth just a question on um CTE
across the state is there a uh specific
course or curricula that required for
all CTE to offer or is it each one
decided by their The Local School uh no
thank you there is no requirement of
what is offered at each school they are
uh locally developed uh each Center is
required to have uh a regional advisory
committee made up of representes from
each of the school districts as well as
the key business Industries in the area
with the intent of developing industry
uh CTE programs to fill the need for the
industry in that region with the intent
that students will complete the program
and stay in their area to support the
local economy thank you very much Mr
you thank you very much and I apologize
uh representative Woodcock for calling a
representative Woodside Mr Woodside
lives two houses from me in
havil that's mild thank you uh do we
have any other hands
there uh yes is represent Tanner did you
have your hand
up uh no
okay I don't see any other hands there
nor do I see hands up here so if there's
no uh uh additional people do we have
anybody in the uh waiting list uh ribson
Hobson no I don't see any hands raised
okay so at this point I will like to uh
close this public hearing we do have on
this particular Bill about 10 minutes
here uh I'd like to entertain a motion
to uh move forward into ex or we will
move forward in the executive session I
would like to entertain a motion from
representative
cordelli thank you Mr chairman I would
like to move on to pass on House Bill
304 second is there a
second representative B seconds that
represent represent B SE is that motion
is there any
discussion yeah repr B yeah just a a
point for transportation and hopefully
the committee will discuss
Transportation within the district I
know this came up last time where it's
easier for me for student in Lichfield
the shorter distance to go to Alber for
the
CTE or even to Manchester for a CTE
course then somebody in Manchester on
the West Side traveling across the city
in a whole lot shorter time and and
districts probably so hopefully one of
the things hopefully the committee will
discuss is in District
transportation thank you are there
further any further
discussion Mr chair representative luno
thank you very much Mr chair um yeah you
you referenced the the commission to
study school funding and and its work in
the CTE and you and I worked on that um
significantly too and I I I absolutely
um you know plan to support this
legislation I do think it's something
that comes from the comes out of the
commission recommendations but but um
but I also feel strongly that um that
the committee should indicate what uh
what you said in your remarks as regards
to the proportional representation of
the membership uh appointed to the
commission so I think as long as the
committee report includes
um uh statements to that effect and we
can have your um confirmation of that
then then I would certainly um lend my U
wholehearted support behind um this um
this
Bill thank you uh I don't want to speak
a whole lot on the bill because I did
present it but uh the my intent that
what I said should be reflected in our
record in the committee report in the
committee report that's correct thank
you very much Mr chair you morning
welcome uh Dave not seeing any other uh
hands flying here for discussion or in
this room uh we have a motion on table
the motion was ought to pass made by
representative cordelli and and second
by representative bone uh Madame Clark
would you please call the
role representative cordelli yes
representative bone yes representative
Allard yes representative leakas yes
representative Moffett yes
representative Hobson
yes uh representative
Andress able to
vote okay uh represent
L representative sod yes representative
Miler yes representative luno yes
representative Shaw yes representative
Cornell
yes representative Tanner yes
representative Ellison yes
representative Mullen yes representative
Le yes representative Woodcock yes
representative lad yes 18
Z
thank repres B is ask that this be put
on consent is there any objection not
see any it's on consent I would like to
thank thank the whole committee for that
it was a 99 vote in terms of parties
that shows this vote and shows our
intent we want to work for the kids to
help
CTE and I'd like to see PE the criteria
for getting on this committee that you
love kids and that you are wanting to
see our CTE programs get the fair shape
in terms of tuition and
transportation and that's not a party
issue that's a non-party issue so
there's two cents worth again um so
thank you very much to all of you uh we
have representative
Ford representative Ford uh you had your
hand
unmute excuse me Mr chair I am online
now I have a a video camera well
congratulations thank you good to see
vote got did you represent for no I
didn't but I can if it's if it's in
agreement with rep representative Ford
were you on during that vote I was yes
okay so so we will modify that it's just
a technology thing so not a problem and
is are is there any objection from
anybody here he was here and he's
expressing his so it would be what
yes Mel are you agreeing to that yes
thank you very much so again now
190 thank you so we have uh about four
minutes to spare by this clock before we
go into our next bill which would be uh
613 which is going to be special
education uh Aid assistance and so we'll
wait a few minutes if somebody needs to
take a break raid the refrigerator go
for
again stop
yeah not really but you
this
[Music]
States my warranty is up on myu well
that's what I get too oh your extended
warranty is coming
up constantly always at dinner
[Music]
time time my husband's uh vehicle was at
1977 so one day he said he took the
call oh my God that it was price listen
toy to get that on one of
our and the one they were calling on had
260,000
mil one of my V calling on
well you call me
oh
yeah yes so I I'm not going to bearing
there I think it's it's going fine I
think we're in a good spot the only
thing I wonder is if someone wants to
speak at the last minute know how do we
how does that well they if they're an
attendee
see them you can scroll through the list
and say okay I see some folks that we
don't have any card or any information
on and doesn't say that they don't want
they didn't sign earlier so I've been
writing down all the attendees I haven't
been
matching I was doing it
[Music]
more found one here okay they were told
that if they wanted to speak they had
to sign
up so if someone comes in at the last
minute you
read we only have two people
I would think they should
be they come in and they want to speak
and they didn't do it we got to give
IES
okay yeah
he sponsor oh okay so I should raise him
to panel so he should want raise him up
to a
panelist that St Smith you know he's
from Charlestown oh yeahi we turn off
your mic until you're ready so this one
ahead hey Rick Rick Rick I've got a I've
got a question what is what is the
status of our uh assistant uh for our
office assistant for this session do you
do you have any report on that is Judith
going to be working with us or what's
the status thing Judy's not working with
us Mel um okay it is a gall Lindsay
Force here is committee assistant um
I've not met
Lindsay um it's the committee room is
totally locked up and the building is
locked up the only place we can go to is
from here down to the head and back okay
um so there's no no a water even
available so thank thank you for the
clarification and the extra information
okay we're gonna go ahead and open up
the hearing here for uh
613 and once again I'm the prime sponsor
of this bill so I'm stepping away from
the mic and uh representative cordelli
will be running this meeting thank you
uh thank you Mr chairman can can I ask a
question the after the first bill you
told us how many people had signed in
Pro and and con on the bill can we have
Bill okay sure
thanks um I'd like to open the uh
committee uh hearing on uh HB 613
relative to state aid to school
districts with special education and
I'll call on the prime sponsor
representative lad to introduce the
[Music]
Bill thank you very much representative
cordelli uh for the record my name is
Rick lad I hail from hail New Hampshire
Grafton
4 uh this bill HB 613 addresses the
issue of special education Aid some of
you may know that as cat Aid that name
is disappearing we now use uh special
special education Aid um some basic
facts about this special education Aid
that we have here uh only 15% of the
funds necessary to pay for mandated
special education services are provided
by the federal government only 20% of
the funds necessary to pay for mandated
special education services are PRI
provided by the state of New Hampshire
so there's total of
35% the remaining 65% of the funds
necessary pay to pay for mandated
special education services are borne by
local school district
taxpayers local school district budgets
must be finalized prior to the start of
the next school year and before the
number of special education students and
Associated services are actually
known I think many of you have
experienced the situation where you're
in a school district and during the
course of a year you have students
arrive from another uh local that have a
significant severe handicapping
condition that
requires uh special education services
that qualify for the old catastrophic
Aid or special education
Aid where does the money come from well
that's an issue because our the money is
course we're talking about money in the
preceding year that the budgets are
based upon but the formula states that
the the first three and a half times the
average cost per pupil in the state and
let's say roughly the average cost of a
pupil in the state is $116,000 make a
figure up it's close to that and so the
district will have to multiply that
figure by three and a half times before
they got any aid from the state of New
Hampshire up to 10 times that amount the
the district will kind uh the state will
kick in between three and a half And1
times 80% of those costs and the the the
school district uh chips in the 20%
beyond that the state pays for this is a
significant burden on um school
districts and the issue uh this is
another issue which uh we discussed this
previous year in terms of uh categorical
Aid the special education the building
CTE programs and uh struggled and and
and of course it really wasn't
underneath the area of adequacy it adey
has differentiated Aid in it which is
Special Ed but it doesn't take in
account this level of funding which is
necessary I want to give you an example
here I'll go back to the issue of a
$166,000 up to three and a half times so
the school district would have to pay
$56,000 before the state started kicking
in if the costs of this student were
roughly
$99,000 you would take that
$56,000 and subtract it from the 99 you
come out with
$443,000 that is above that three and a
half
times the state is responsible paying
80% of the cost above the special ed
education cap so if the take the the 10
the 80% out which would be out of the 43
which is
34,400 the the local is going to have to
capture another
$8,600 so the total cost for this
student to the Local District for a
student that has um a need for $999,000
the program The District would have to
kick in about $64,500
that is you know not necessarily in all
those budgets and so they don't have a
trust fund which they can delve back
into so one of the concepts I was
looking at earlier and I've expressed it
to the commission before that what
happens if we drop this amount uh down
to two and a half times so if you take
two and a half and multiply that by 16
you come up with a bottom line of um uh
subtracting the of the uh it would be
$40,000 subtracting that from the 59 and
you end up with um the state's portion
would actually be a $
47,2 I bottom line of all this there
would be a savings to the district if we
bounced it back to two and a half of
$12,800
but there's more to this story if the
state appropriates only X number dollars
and we back it off to two and a half
we're going to be probably enrolling
engaging more students that qualify for
cat a there could be another thousand
kids and so if we appropriate the same
amount of dollar we're just going to
sprinkle that money all over and would
be less support for these kids so this
again is another issue it's a it's issue
which has to be
addressed um this bill is it's been
presented more of a
placeholder and hoping that we wouldn't
be in the middle of this uh coid which
is you know constricting what we're able
able to do and what we're not able to do
but this is an issue that also needs a
lot of work there are we are working on
an amendment that could be possibly put
into this bill which would allow and and
move us
towards um a an insurance pool where all
the school districts in the state would
enter into an insurance pool and you
would have an insurance premium which
would help pay for these kids and so
wouldn't have these unexpected costs
hitting you but that's a huge huge issue
we have some of the work already done on
that working with the Department of
Education uh and I'm hoping that we
could probably get something together
within the next few weeks to try even to
amend this bill so and to shut this off
and be concluding our where we are as
it's written right now there is a
possible savings a good savings on the
state would have to kick and it's taking
the money and shifting it from the local
to the
state that's a good thing if you're on
the local school board um then the state
has to determine okay where are they
going to find the money for these
additional costs that's where we are but
I'm looking at from policy
consideration districts are struggling
with CAD Aid this is one way that we can
start that discussion and in fact if we
follow through in this there will be
some savings to districts thank you very
much for the opport to speak thank you
uh do we have any questions for the
chairman represent
t uh thank you uh chairman um I am all
for uh this bill uh giving the local
taxpayer a break on special education my
only concern is I and I'm not I would
have to really do some research on it
but uh it seems like the state set sets
Caps or sets caps on pockets of money
that's used for special education and if
um if more people apply for it more
local districts apply for it uh and the
money isn't there it's then distributed
on a percentage basis um is that what's
going to happen with
this is that to
me what you described uh represent
Tanner is exactly what's happening with
Career Technical education as well you
know we often times say you're going to
get 70% of this but actuality it might
be
56% um what we need to do here is if we
recog I'm I'm addressing this one from a
a policy focus a policy perspective and
I I think it is good policy that we um
look at where where the state is where
the federal government is on this and
they're contributing basically 35% the
65% is on your local district and for a
small District that they just can't
survive like that uh I had a small
District right next door to us in havil
it's called permont they had two
catastrophic Aid students enroll in one
year and it basically drove them under
and what it ends up doing they have to
fund that they either take out a tax
anticipation note or they subtract
dollars allocated to other operational
services within the facility which often
times is curriculum and instruction and
to support this program the dollars have
to come from somewhere so uh from a
policy perspective I understand what
you're saying but I also see there is an
opportunity if this is properly
administered and if we have the funding
there then we're going to alleviate some
of the B burden for these smaller
districts and on Manchester as
well followup on that
please you you move a little closer to
the um M volume was a little bit low on
our end
here could I have a followup yes follow
up uh thank you C uh representative
cordellia it's a little bit hard to hear
you sometimes I don't know if it's hard
to hear me yeah um but I just want to
make sure that I made my point and that
the point was that um the state can
still cap the amount of money that
they're going to spend so even though
we're down upshifting which I think is a
great idea and I thoroughly um support
the insurance pool but um if if this is
upshifting and the state still puts a
cap on everything it doesn't necessarily
mean that the local um the local people
will get more money uh and also um I
wanted to just say that the LBA hasn't
given us a fiscal note on this as
well
is that to me yeah I think that was to
you yes I I and follow up to this uh
represent Tanner I spoke with the uh
Department of Education yesterday
regarding that they're working on this
they really are having a difficult time
trying to identify so if we drop it to
two and a half times how many students
now start uh are caught and eligible for
some of the state funding that's what
they're trying to figure out um and I I
understand they're going to have that
information for us here within the next
week or so so um once again uh this is a
bill that I I think that we just need to
introduce and hold it until we can you
know get more information and then do
what we need to do with it
later thank
you yeah represent may you have a
question yes I'm wondering about whether
there's any uh provision in this bill or
consideration of the assessment of the
efficacy of this
instruction even and the present funding
I support the idea of additional funding
I recognize there's a need for it but
when I look at what the results are I
don't see any data that says any outside
professional has assessed whether or not
it the schools seem to be doing their
own assessment and
then somehow people graduate who don't
perform at the level of other people and
that concerns
me if that's a question to me
representative Ford um the the students
we're talking about here uh in the state
approximately that have re eligible for
about 800 students these are students
that are done through the IEP process
and many of them are in these facilities
as a result of professionals above and
beyond the school district making those
diagnosis um yes I agree that
accountability for all the programs uh
is an issue uh Department of Education
unfortunately is I'll say it underst
staffed in many of these departments and
needs that support in a uh in terms of
staff to have it and also we as a
legislator legislature have to give them
the authority to get some accountability
we're dealing with Federal legislation
as well the idea and um that's a pretty
big act to
tackle thank you
um I see representative luno has
question for representative I believe
thank thank you very much Mr chair and
thank you very much um representative
lad for for taking my question um as you
know U special education was a was a
significant part of the um of the
commission to study school funding's um
work and um and I I I guess what what um
what I want to ask you about
particularly is in the context of the um
of the commission's uh final report and
recommendations they talk about um
significant changes to data collection
done by the department that would um
that would probably make it um easier
for the Department to to evaluate the
fiscal cost of of this type of policy
and I was wondering if you could um talk
a little bit about what the um what the
department is doing right now in order
to um to to arrive at a um at a fiscal
note and then I guess the second part of
my question also stemming back to the um
to the commission's report is uh
wondering if this Bill U um talks about
modifying the determination year of the
special education Aid because as you
know it follows um it comes a year late
which um when when when looking at um at
um uh High um needs students can uh can
still put tremendous budgetary pressure
on um school districts so thanks very
much representative Vlad and and I'll
just I'll try to answer that briefly
here for you represent luno we do have
uh an individual from the Department of
Education that was like to speak and
from special education and some of your
questions might be best sent
there you know asked in a few moments
question yeah thank you acting chair
representative lad thanks for taking my
question just um I'm trying to uh learn
some of these review the bills via uh
the internet versus hard copy makes it
more difficult for me to keep noting but
I didn't see specifically any place
where you identified in the Bill's
language the insurance pool I heard you
speak about the insurance pool a minute
ago so my question was as regards the
insurance pool where would that money
from this this is a proposed amendment
that has not been fully developed right
now representative Woodcock um it's uh
been worked with for the last year and a
half and on and off uh the uh Commission
of education's aware of it school
districts are certainly aware of it and
very supportive of trying to set up some
kind of an insurance pool much like your
sick La Bank you might have within a
school district for employees they can
borrow from the bank to and and they
contribute to the bank so that that's a
positive thing so I I do have in front
of me uh some of that proposed language
uh but there's a lot to it
representative Woodcock that we need
further definition on as far as uh um
you know some kind of a cost estimator
legal indemnification issues um uh
process to determine eligible insurance
carriers available for the pool um uh
these are types of fiscal things that
have yet to be developed where still in
the discussion stages and quite frankly
it it may be premature to be putting
something like this forward unless we
have all those answers and um there are
some folks out in the hinterland in the
districts are just so excited about
possibly going this they like to see it
happen yesterday um to help them with
the the cost of this this one area of
education so um you're correct there's
you haven't seen anything I haven't seen
some of it I've seen the purpose
statements I've seen um how the pool
pool might work uh much the policy stuff
but as far as the fiscal management and
the business aspects of it I haven't so
my hopes are up but I I since I honestly
think that to do all this within the
next two and a half three weeks is is is
like climbing Mount
Everest uh 10 times over so um the only
thing that this bill does is Scratch Out
3.5 and put 2.5 in
um thank you representative that that
that eases my mind because I couldn't
find it on in text and I didn't have a
hard copy thank you you're
welcome if there no further questions
for representative
lad
excuse okay there
was
yeah um there was a question from the uh
viewing public U The Honorable Dan mire
I believe has a question for
representative
lad uh thank you Mr chairman um not
specifically for representative lad I
wanted to testify on the bill maybe I
don't know the procedure quite right
there's so many questions uh I this is a
point of order from myself uh I don't
believe uh a person that's testifying
can be asked a question by a
non-committee
member I would
agree
Sor
soor um we'll move on uh to the next um
person who wants to testify and I'll
turn the Reigns back over to Chairman L
thank you very much uh represent Cordell
I'd like to invite to the uh meeting
right now uh Rebecca Wilson from New
Association good morning chairman Laden
committee members thanks for allowing me
to speak today sorry for the it took a
minute for me to get promoted here to
it's always nice to feel promoted so uh
my name is Becky Wilson and I am the
director of governmental relations for
the New Hampshire school boards
Association and we are in support of HB
613 and its current proposed form I
realized there's some discussion about
some amendments and things like that and
I will try not to be repetitive or
redundant because several of the points
that we were going to discuss today have
already been talked about but certainly
uh one one of our longstanding
resolutions that's adopted by our
members and continually reaffirmed uh is
to reduce the threshold for determining
the local share of special costs uh to
two times the state average uh for the
general education cost and while 613 as
written doesn't completely get us down
to that desired threshold it certainly
is a strong positive step towards that
goal uh and to Chairman lad's Point
earlier uh these costs certainly
uh would assist meeting the needs of our
most vulner vulnerable students in our
districts and allow um some of those
costs to be defrayed directly from those
uh over those lowi incidents
disabilities um as we're aware across
the state special ed funding is
certainly a resource that is in very
short supply and districts are obligated
to ensure that our students receive the
special ed services supports and
placements that they need to succeed
educationally in the least restrictive
environment and for some some students
that means creating some very um
intensive needs programs within their
district and for some students that
means going outside of the district to
look for specially approved programs for
these students uh regardless districts
have to meet those obligations
regardless of and without consideration
of the cost we are putting the students
first in terms of what their needs are
uh Schoolboard budgets can be stretched
by the Intensive educational needs
placements and programs and merited
sometimes midyear um by changes in a
family's District of residence or by
changes in student need after the
budgets have been approved so providing
any additional reimbursement through
House Bill 613 would provide schools
with much Aid and particularly again to
Chairman lad's Point our smaller
districts where Sometimes some
unanticipated uh placements or programs
can cost far beyond even the three and a
half uh times the estimated per pupil
expenditure
um we have had some placements for
students that can cost upwards of
$300,000 per year um and for some
districts even our larger districts that
is a very high cost to incur um so we
certainly would uh support HB 613 and
additional state aid for these costs as
districts continue to meet their
obligations to students and I'm happy to
take any questions from the committee
thank you very much Becky are there
questions for Becky Wilson New Hampshire
not seeing any hands thank you very much
for your testimony thank you so much I'd
like to next invite uh uh Stephen
Smith thank you Mr chairman and members
of the committee for hearing me today
I'm Representative Steven Smith Sullivan
County District 11 aworth Charlestown go
and Lang and lemster and Washington yes
Mr Smith did go to
Washington the um the town that I live
in Charlestown recently went through a
pretty brutal fight with Fall Mountain
School District um the consideration was
whether the town withdraw or not and
this is relevant because it made people
in the five towns that are in the
district actually start talking about
education funding it was vicious and
polarizing there were neighbor against
neighbor Town against town but they all
agreed on one thing that special
education costs are a burden they feel
like all these regulations are coming in
from other places and uh there's no
check attached to that so here are all
these other things that you need to do
and there's no funding behind it so even
people that spend a good portion of
every day attacking each other we're
unified on this issue and that's
important um it isn't like an interest
group came together and they gathered
support and we got a bunch of names
these were folks who did not want to
agree with each other yet they did on
this issue
I am not a math Wizard and I trust my
good friend your chairman to come up
with numbers but what I'm asking the
committee is do something um everyone
agrees on this when you have a child
move into the district that has an i AP
or that has special needs attached to
them that cost the district money this
is really disruptive um sometimes it can
involve a higher there has to be a
one-on-one par so this bill is a great
step forward I don't know if it's the
answer but that isn't the point the
point is that we do something so the
education committee as a policy matter
can pass this bill or whatever amended
version you come up with and set the
policy that the state does indeed need
to do more so I guess I'll just leave
you with please do something please do
not do nothing thank you and uh not
being an expert and having an 11:00
appointment I apologize Mr chair but I
cannot take questions thank you very
appointment okay uh so thank you very
much we will move on to the next I
believe represent Judy
eron
Judy good morning uh chairman lad and
committee
members um I am representative Judy
Aaron I represent Sullivan County
district 7 uh aworth Goan langon lemster
and
Washington and I
we'll keep this pretty short and sweet I
did send you testimony
electronically um in representing these
small towns uh in the rural rural part
of the State uh I constantly hear about
the problems that our select boards and
Boards of Education have in meeting the
uh requirements and and financial
obligations
for uh education in especially special
education students and so I feel very
strongly that this bill um will be very
very helpful um by lowering the
threshold from three and a half to two
and a half we we're going to increase
the amount of state aid available for
these school districts uh and for the
costs of these special education
students and so I cannot add any more to
what's already been said and I don't
want to take up any more of your time
but I do hope that you will support this
and pass it through and and get some
much needed relief from the state uh to
our smaller towns and even our bigger
towns and
municipalities but um specifically my
small towns they need some help so and I
hope you can do it thank you thank you
very much representative Aaron uh Ron
Hobson do we have any other folks that
are up for Testimony no so we're down
through our list uh of folks how many
people did we have signed up on on that
bill see I can go down through the list
here we had uh let's see one two three
four people testifying in support nobody
testifying against it um we have a total
of 1 two 3 four five 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
total people that signed up uh uh
regarding this bill uh of the those uh
we
had all but one
supporting so I will conclude
this
me Mr chair excuse we will take question
is there one in the attendee list yes we
have one person in the attendee list I
intend to try and give some support
there um uh The Honorable
hi Mr chairman and members of the
committee for the record my name is Dan
Maguire um I was a representative from
2011 to 2016 as a member of the finance
committee and my first term I dealt with
uh education as one of the
responsibilities on the finance
committee so I'm somewhat
familiar um with this area possibly out
of date uh but I I wanted to make two
comments um with regard to um
representative lad's testimony uh first
of all he seems
to um think that somehow there's a
difference between local taxpayers and
state level taxpayers in the sense that
um unburdening one and and extra
burdening the other would make a
difference but in fact the two groups
are essentially the same groups of
people um the state does does not have a
magical you know Money Tree behind the
state house it's it's the same set of
taxpayers are paying both bills um local
taxes tend to be more noticeable because
people explicitly write two checks a
year uh whereas the r estate taxes are
paid invisibly through business
transactions and and other things um so
you would think that this bill there
therefore is essentially a wash that you
know one set of you're you're taking
from the left pocket instead of the
right pocket but that's not quite true
because the inevitable result of this
bill will be more spending on uh special
ed than there was previously and the
reason for that is that this bill the
people who make decisions about how much
spending there will be on special ed are
the local school districts and at least
my experience is that the state
department of education has essentially
zero oversight over that that the local
school districts just send a number to
to the state and and this is and the and
the state sends a check and so um when
somebody else pays a a larger proportion
of your bill you're like more likely to
spend more than if you are paying that
proportion of your bill so the local
school districts who were paying X and
are now paying less than that are likely
to spend more it's just human
nature all right the other thing I want
to talk about is that at least at the
time and well you can see it today is
that certain towns overuse this um this
uh program more than others certain
towns are Big Spenders in this area
compared to others and after this
hearing is over I'll send you all a
current spreadsheet that shows this
total amount of money is roughly $30
million a year that the state sends to
towns and I'll show you how much each
Town gets and the and the calculation
and there are certain towns uh I'll name
three Bedford Dover and marac um which
are Big Spenders they get um uh much
more than half of what marac get what
Manchester gets for example um they each
get close to a million dollars of that
30 million uh Manchester gets about 1.6
million even though they're about a
quarter of the size of of Manchester if
that
so there are certain towns that that
spend a lot in this area and and
therefore this is not
necessarily an EV evenly distributed
program it's it's
it's encourages big spend ERS in some
sense and um so one suggestion I have
for you to improve this bill would be to
to allow the Department of Education to
do some oversight put in the bill that
you would hire four or six or some
number of Auditors and allow them to
actually audit the special ed spending
in those programs and try to get some
kind of uniformity among the towns in
terms of their decision making because I
think that would overall spend save
money and um therefore you could
increase uh the amount of of um
percentage that the state spends without
necessarily causing the state to
actually spend more more dollars if you
see what I mean so thank you very much
Mr chairman and members of the committee
thank you very much uh honorable Maguire
Dan not see any hands raised uh thank
you very much for your
testimony um at this point in time we
have no further people in the queue is
that correct so I'm going to close this
hearing and uh we will enter into the
last hearing set for this morning which
will be HB
513 relative to the degree granting
authority of Signum University and
relative the authority of the higher
education
Commission that starts at no that bill
starts yeah that starts at 11:30 so um
we have a little bit of time here so
we'll take a break for what about uh 20
minutes okay I got to my computer's out
of
juice I'm
gonna no not for this old one but I do
do I'll set this thing up and maybe
[Music]
machine right
here I love that house inside of it one
whole wall was
Cas oh good okay so let me see if this
works and this works not I can just plug
in tie in right there
good
here
minute I think there's room on
that
any oh yeah there you go least I can
look at one
of that you sure let's see if we can
certain note to self bring
power you are de hson sorry hson I'm
nice toet yeah I've met you before yeah
been a
while that was your last time not in
education am I pronouncing your name
right soie
yes I know representative
Al this guy get the great and Layon is
it Layon l l on just like that ER L not
laying L on yeah from
der and
uh
[Music]
serious
I I I'm good but I don't have any of the
controls on this one right now I got to
be all I can do is wave my magic
hands there you are um my blood pressure
was like 80
over7 figure out what was going on
so they finally moved the drain
and
cells then give me a second
one you know we like your body to try to
recover itself
well you know I'm 78 years old a while I
[Music]
feel
I
like
[Music]
is this thing working right
that
computer yes well we shut that off I
mean I what it
is the
motion it's just so distressing might I
everybody it's hard every week Wednesday
o one of them is a free spirit
[Music]
she
I
[Music]
he's that kid is he's failing everything
to
one
of's
teing so one of them is full has been
[Music]
F special he's just one of the quiet
kids that you just don't know him you
can't read his mind because he doesn't
say much well the other
day
assignment in he came to my house he
also lives on a farm all kinds of
there's
dogs you know so his
noise
disappear they never
got and she said they
said sa you made sure everyone was saved
and then they disappeared it's some sort
of and I looked it up online and it's
some sort of a
glitch administrator again so I told my
da write a note to the teacher and tell
to see if they can retrieve them at that
daughter unless you you know get all
yours done get everything else done then
he did a 9 he did I helped him with some
English assignment that he had read a
Fant
young what a great book really very
thought had to read the whole book work
with him I had to prompt him and ask
question anyway
um he
submitted interview he interviewed my
husband um and got his View and develop
the view he did all that he submitted it
then he was missing two
sections so I went over the rubric I
looked at all the what the teacher asked
for and everything so I made sure did
everything that was asked
for
said and I by I said what did the
teacher say he said that most kids
at least four to five
pages and I said it said three to four
paragraphs and he said yeah he said the
teacher said that was a typographical
error
something I said you
write that teacher and you explained to
him that you followed the written
assignment and you remind him that you
sent an email to him and said I can't
find the assignment online and his
response was it's there
somewhere
seriously so he finally found it with
the help of me and his mother we went
through onto the Google Website and we
went through and we search search
finally it came up it was something
there so anyway I said don't even bother
trying to
that you did you were supposed to you
get I said get a good grade on an and
teer
holy
back
I figured everyone hear me but I really
don't care
long
[Music]
I Haven seen
my
expert experts experts in their area
these are folks that arep flight
administrators well I apologize I said
anything to offend anyone but it was my
feeling my opinion my personal
experience
and
yeah I'm not
sure I haven't really met you yet how
are
[Music]
based they're
get
surgery I thought back and teach the
next
day for about four five
okay I get out and walk and all that you
know What Hurts the Most sitting in a
that spare
[Laughter]
High
I was
dayes
behind it doesn't get old I
mean
an
interesting story about the portraits in
the
back his daughter
toor H
met to try and get an
ambassador to break up their
own
wow I I just talking with Virginia Davis
down in the visitor
center
history
[Music]
John's
brother
I
also never
covered of I said I can
identify
experience I miss you
guys family my grandfathered the two
[Music]
Plaza went down to Washington DC
actually
Married Girl by the name
the
[Music]
fascinating
Motoring
good a good morning everybody we're back
to it it's uh 11:30 by the clock here in
uh
203 uh so I'd like to uh go to our next
bill please um that will be HB
513 um relative to the degree granting
authority of Signum University and
relative to the authority of the higher
education
commission um is everybody out there in
the field ready to go ahead I want to
ask that question so I got the thumb
okay thank you very much uh
Mel uh so at at this point in time I'd
like to uh introduce or have the prime
sponsor of the bill that be
representative Jim Allard uh come
forward and and and speak
please thank you Mr chairman for the
record my name is Jim Allard I represent
marac district 21 comprising the towns
of pitsfield and EP and it is a it's a
pleasure for me to come before you this
morning uh to introduce the house bill
513 for those of you that were with us
last session uh this is a familiar Bill
to you for those that are new to the
committee uh this is a bill that will
essentially open the final gate to an
organization known as Signum Unity
University uh to headquarter and do
business here in New Hampshire sigam
University is a distance learning uh
institution uh relying on faculty and
students from around the globe uh but
the president of that institution is a
New Hampshire native and wanted to bring
his university home uh to locate I
believe in the town
of New
Hampshire and organization that has been
successfully doing business from a
headquarters in Maryland up to this
point and so it is somewhat known in the
academic Community it has gone through
all the wickets at the federal level and
has been reviewed here in this state and
approved by the higher education
commission uh for those of you not
familiar with the higher education
commission it's comprised of the
chancellor of the University syst system
the presidents of the four uh colleges
and
University as well as representation
from the community colleges and they are
a rigorous organization that put anyone
who wants to teach in this state through
their Paces to make sure that they are
academically up to Snuff as it were and
uh before that approval is granted
Signum has passed that Approval Pro
process and as a final step in that
process we here in the legislature get
to
authorize that institution uh to conduct
business within the granite state and so
this bill 5113 is
to both permit Signum to go forward uh
but also to once again
delineate uh the Dual responsibility of
the higher education commission to
approve and we as the legislative body
to
authorize uh Institutes of Higher
Learning to do business in our state so
with that chair I'd be happy to take
questions thank you very much
representative Allard are there any
Allard not yes uh representative
woodcock
thank you uh Mr chairman representative
Valley good to speak with you again this
year uh a question as regards the bill
uh text when it appears to be approved
by the higher education commission uh is
that a new insert this year
representative
Allen uh yes it is representative wood
thank you for the question um it's to
clarify uh in in more firm language than
we had had in the bill when it
us thank you Mr chairman M thank you
representative thank you are there
further
questions not seeing any hands um thank
you very much representative valard uh
we'll move on to the next individual uh
that's signed up to speak and that would
be Lori Alden is that correct or Cory oh
Cory
okay yes Corey Olson has signed up here
next excellent good morning thank you
for having me my name is Corey olssen
I'm the president and founder of Signum
University uh I did originally establish
Signum University in Delaware where I
lived in Dover in the capital of the
state but when I moved back to New
Hampshire I I went to middle school and
high school uh here in Amherst and
currently live in Hollis I did bring
Signum with me back into the state let
me first explain a little bit about who
we are and what we're doing at Signum
the mission of Signum University is to
establish an open and globally
accessible digital campus that reduces
student costs provides a vibrant online
academic community that Fosters
exceptional teaching and opportunities
for intellectual engagement and ensures
fair and generous treatment of our
employees and students students alike
Signum has several different programs
this our Central program is a master's
degree in language and literature an MA
degree with concentrations in Germanic
philology imaginative literature toling
studies and classical medieval and
Renaissance literature we now have over
a hundred students who are enrolled in
and enjoying our program making it one
of the largest ma only programs in
language and literature in the country
we also offer a number of other
non-credit bearing programs these are
totally separate from our degree bearing
programs uh we we host a number of open
literature discussions providing
thousands of hours of completely free
academic engagement for the public we're
also hosting a series of extracurricular
language arts clubs for children book
clubs creative writing clubs and
language clubs we know that
extracurricular options for kids have
been limited during the pandemic and
we've wanted to step in and help out
with that a week and a half ago our
program was unanimously approved clubs
program was unanimously approved by the
New Hampshire board of education for
participation in the new learn
everywhere initiative and we're excited
to give kids more fun options for
learning especially in the current
pandemic
circumstances recently we've been
working with one of our current students
to begin free book and writing clubs for
inmates in the main prison system where
she works the program has sadly been put
on hold for a while due to a coid
outbreak in the main prisons but we're
hoping to move forward with that
initiative a few months down the road in
2018 Signum underwent a rigorous
comprehensive review before the higher
education commission a committee as you
know consisting of many of the most
distinguished higher education
Professionals in the state Dr gustofson
former president of s of Southern New
Hampshire University served as the chair
of our evaluation committee the result
of that review was a recommendation that
our ma program be approved in the state
of New Hampshire and the review team
provided as they always do a list of
recommendations that they wanted to see
us address in the following two years
years prior to our first standard
follow-up review which was scheduled for
fall of 2020 the higher education
commission approved our program
officially and unanimously in 2020 we
officially began the next stage of our
credentialing process which is our
application for accreditation we're
applying for accreditation from the
distance education accrediting
commission we have passed through the
first preliminary stage of the
accreditation review and we're currently
engaged in stage two we're hoping that
our accreditation review will be
complete in either June 2021 or January
2022 though the time frame is largely
out of our hands of course this past
fall Dr gustofson uh requested an update
on our progress towards that list of
recommendations that the that the higher
education commission gave uh for us to
work on in preparation for our next
review the higher education commission
was so satisfied with our excellent
progress towards these goals that they
voted in October 2020 Again by unanimous
vote to postpone our review our next
review our follow-up review to the fall
of 2021 extending our initial approval
period by a full year in that hearing Dr
gustofson also testified that he had
read our full set of accreditation
materials and that he was confident that
we would receive a satisfactory review
by from the accrediting board these are
Signum credentials for the awarding of
degree granting status by the New
Hampshire legislature we've completed
every necessary step along the way and
we've been vetted and reviewed on
multiple occasions by those in whom the
state of New Hampshire has vested
authority to evaluate the quality of
institutions of higher education we
remain in contact with the higher
education commission and we're looking
forward to a lifelong relationship with
that body as we undergo regular reviews
and evaluations from them every few
years as is right and as is stipulated
by law we embrace the accountability
that the that the higher education
commission offers as they continue their
work of ensuring that higher education
in New Hampshire is held to a high
standard
at this time I feel I need to pause to
address a concern of which I've just
recently been made aware it's come to my
attention that one of my communications
from last January uh has been receiving
some discussion and uh has seemed to
cause some consternation last January we
were nearing the end of the house
discussion of Signum previous Bill since
there seemed still to be some
misunderstandings at the time I reached
out by email to Mr luno who is the most
vocal of those opposed to the measure I
proposed a meeting at which we could
discuss the issues together and perhaps
come to a better understanding but I
never received any resp response from
him in a hearing with the Senate
education committee a couple weeks ago
Senator Khan informed me that Mr luno
had been offended by my email and that
Mr luno had thought its tone was
threatening if this is the case I
certainly apologize I declared in my
email my intention of publicly rebutting
the statements that Mr luno had already
written into the public record as I felt
to be my duty my intention of course was
to avoid any such public debates by
resolving things with a civilized
private discussion instead it was
certainly never my intention to make
anyone feel uneasy that email came at
the end of a long and frustrating series
of hearings and discussions and in
retrospect I now realize it was perhaps
rather too intense in my Expressions if
that made you feel uncomfortable Mr Leno
I'm very sorry for that to return to the
main matter it is now 202 21 and we're
almost a year into the coid pandemic in
the last year remote learning and online
education have taken a central place in
our Educational Systems it is clear that
good online education is imperative for
the future of Education in America
Signum has spent the last 10 years
pioneering a remote learning approach
that makes excellence in teaching and
learning available to students in New
Hampshire and Beyond since April we've
been offering to assist teachers and
institutions who have been undertak
taking the difficult and sudden
transition to remote learning brought on
by the circumstances of the pandemic we
have run several mentoring sessions for
teachers at multiple levels helping them
to work through the conversion of their
teaching plans to the online medium
recently I was approached by the
president of a small tribal College in
Minnesota he's been following Signum
program so uh from afar uh and his
college has been struggling to adapt to
the pandemic circumstances he asked for
my advice in helping them to rethink
their whole pedagogical approach because
he'd really like to have their college
follow the model that Signum has
developed we've begun working with them
to assist them in their transition to a
more vibrant online teaching approach as
they seek new and innovative ways to
serve their students better and move
forward into the 21st century it has
been many years since a new institution
of higher education has been formed in
the state of New Hampshire ours is the
first such Bill to come to the New
Hampshire legislature during the
legislative careers of the vast majority
of its representatives and senators
in this bill you have the opportunity to
show that New Hampshire supports
education and innovation in the last
year Signum has already begun to be
looked at by our peers as a viable model
for the future of higher education we
are working hard to make Signum
University a school that New Hampshire
can be proud to call her own I'd be
happy to take any questions that you
might
have thank you very much for your
testimony uh Corey uh are there any
questions
for Mr Olen
around okay uh yeah represent Woodside
you have your hand up then
representative Tanner you have yours up
as well it's representative Woodcock Mr
chairman representative Woodcock is here
again yeah Woodcock I'm sorry you know I
I know we haven't hav't met
representative so we'll get it
um I do I do have a couple questions uh
Dr Olson sure both from last year to be
honest with you uh one last year uh we
read and I think it's the same woman who
sent testimony this year uh supporting
your program she's a currently a
community college uh instructor over in
Vermont and she sent assemble pie this
year so
that I asked the same question last year
I'll ask it again now but
expanded um and listening you just speak
a moment ago you talk about your ma
programs that expanded to multiple
specifications versus just the one main
uh Core Curriculum you had last year is
that right no that's not right um we
have the same curriculum this year that
we had last year there's been no
expansion of our ma curriculum oh okay I
thought the I thought the different
majes I thought you only had one ma
program last year we do we still do uh I
said that we have four different
concentrations within our ma okay that
that was it okay thank you did you have
four last year as well four
concentrations yes we did okay I may
just finish this then um the students
from last last year through this uh end
of the Academic
Year um how many finished the
program uh during this past year yes uh
six or seven I believe finished during
this last year okay and if I may follow
up Mr chairman so what did they
get at the end of the year in June if
they finish the program and you weren't
an accredited school what do they
actually get for a degree they they get
an acknowledgement that they have
completed our uh program and we shall
award them the official master's degree
when we are awarded the authority to do
so okay so so you just got another
question that was it that was it Mr just
to just to be clear by May Mr chairman
so that means that so at the end they
just got a piece of paper signifying
they finished your program they
completed the program yep thank you very
much thank you Mr Mr lad appreciate it
thank you very much represent Woodcock
Tanner oh you're muted Linda un
issue uh
oh I'm not good at the digital stuff can
you me now barely hear you um I remember
asking you a question about whether
you'd be accepting title uh four funds
and and also uh pel grants and I was
wondering if you had changed on your um
position on that well of course we don't
yet qualify for title 4 participation
until after we complete the
accreditation process so that's not an
issue right now uh we have no plans to
move forward with title 4 funding
because we already have in place more
than sufficient financial support for
our students there is no student who has
ever wanted to attend Signum University
who has ever been barred by Financial
need and a large number of our students
have completed our degree and will
continue to complete our degree without
any charge whatsoever we already have
programs in place for that um we may
pursue that representative Tanner that's
something that we're going to have to I
mean that's as I said that's that's a
stage down the road for us that's after
the accreditation process and the
possibility of participating in federal
funding that would enable pel grants
though we have absolutely no interest in
participating in the student loan
programs uh which are inimical to to our
founding Mission um uh the the the
alleviation of the student debt problem
is one of the one of the
founding concepts of Signum University
um so I'm not going to eliminate the
possibility that we could do that but
even with pelgrin we believe that there
are better ways to make sure that our
education is available we are also in
the process right now by the way I would
add representative Tanner of applying
for scholarships um we have begun a a a
robust grant writing uh program we've
already applied in the last month for
$120,000 worth of Grants uh which are
designed to be dedicated to student
scholarships for our various programs
that's a program that we're continuing
um and these are mostly private grants
that we so far exclusively private
Foundation grants that we're applying
for rather than using Federal funding uh
for this um so there are a number of uh
avenues that we are pursuing because one
of our primary and foundational missions
is to ensure that education can be
available for all students regardless of
financial income um and so participation
in federal pel grants is something that
is one of the options that we may
consider I am still not convinced it is
among the best options uh for student
aid but it is something that we will
consider but as I say for now it's quite
irrelevant to us because we have to
first complete the accreditation process
before we could even begin
that may I have a followup go ahead um I
out of just out of curiosity I don't
remember whether um you had said this
last time but why are you only doing
graduate ma um degrees rather than
starting out with undergraduate um can't
hear you we I can't hear that sure her
question was um and you can obviously
correct me if I but I I know the audio
issue um her question was uh why are we
starting with a graduate degree rather
than beginning with an undergraduate
degree and the answer is that starting
up a new University from scratch with no
funding whatsoever is challenging um and
what we had when we began was a group of
people who were very interested to study
and to study at The Graduate level
starting up a program a focused program
within a single discipline really a pair
of related disciplines the study of
language and literature um uh was uh
therefore enabled us to create a compact
and efficient program that we could uh
we could basically afford to run and
also of course that was my own field so
I could teach in it and I had uh you
know a number of other uh colleagues and
Associates that I had made you know in
my discipline around the world who were
able to come in and teach in that
program um so it was uh you you know
entirely what we were able to do at the
beginning whereas if you attempt to
start uh with a you know with an
undergraduate program you have to begin
with a wide array of different majors
and programs which involves funding for
a wide array of Faculty um and that was
something that was well beyond our means
Signum has never had any funding we've
never had any startup funding we've run
our you know we our tuition is
aggressively low compare our tuition to
any institution out there at the
Master's Degree level um and we are
aggressively below the tuition rates of
almost any other institution our courses
cost $650 per course not per credit per
course uh for our program it's less than
$8,000 uh to do our entire master's
degree um and uh so so with that with
that tuition income and W with mind with
a bunch of it remitted uh for students
who declare themselves to be in
financial need and without any startup
funding or endowment of any kind um we
began from scratch uh and so we began
with a focused narrow Niche program uh
which served the market that I was
already connected to through the podcast
that I was running so that's how we
began with a graduate program I know it
may seem a little bit unusual uh but
under the circumstances that was how
things if involved and
developed thank thank you very much uh
repent luno thank you thank you very
much Mr chair and um and I'd also
appreciate your Indulgence Since U since
um Mr Olsen um referenced U me during
his earlier
testimony as well as a communication
that uh that he sent to me if that's
okay Mr
chair so uh what i' what I'd like to do
is actually actually
um uh read uh a few statements from uh
from the email that uh that Dr Olsen
sent to me on January 7th 2020 and you
know I want to say right up front that
it certainly didn't generate any um any
consternation um in fact it would be
funny if it wasn't so pathetic but um
but uh from this email Dr olssen goes on
to say your statement both in your
motion in the committee session and in
your printed public opinion is puzzling
to say the least even if one disregards
its simple inaccuracies and
misrepresentations Mr luno I have had no
desire to take this discussion to the
Press which I can't help but believe
could end up being very embarrassing for
both you and your party I am very happy
to have all of these details come out
but I have not talked to any reporters
about this because I saw no attempt a no
need to attempt to do so so long as
there was a chance that you would be
reasonable and clear the
record this needn't become any more of a
hassle than it has already been made to
be if you agree to sit down and discuss
this together then I will promise not to
talk to any member of the press until
after our conversation and in closing
this does not have to be a public debate
Mr lunar let me know when you are
willing to talk to clarify matters and
quietly so my first um question to Corey
Olsson is um are those are those words
that
email they are as I explained earlier of
course that as you read I propos to have
a quiet meeting meeting I didn't want to
have a messy public debate um and uh you
know I wanted to resolve things in a
civilized discussion instead there were
inaccuracies in the statement that you
that you wrote Into the public record
which I felt it my responsibility to
rebut uh but as I said I did not wish to
do that in a public way I'd been
approached by several reporters for
comments uh on this and so instead of
merely responding in the Press um I
wrote to you first to offer a chance to
talk about this quietly because I didn't
want I did not have any interest uh in
engaging in a messy public debate so I
offered to talk about it quietly and as
I say I did not want to engage in a
public debate and so when uh the bill
was tabled ultimately and therefore did
not receive the ratification of a house
vote I Let It Drop because I did not
want to engage in a messy public
debate Mr chair okay I I'd like to
interject for a second here um I'd like
to have all conversation directed
towards this Bill thank you with the
looking at the changes right there
approved by the higher education
commission and
authorized that that's what we're
debating right now the rest of it's
already in
statute uh or you know the first part of
that Roman 2
then number number two down below is
what we can should also be debating but
unfortunately we've had this situation
occur in the past uh I'd like to see us
moving forward here and not and if there
is this discussion it would be
appreciated by the entire committee here
that we start discussing that on a on a
private level between the two involved
in this rather than taking up the time
we have right now to rehash this is not
going to get us any closer to a final
resolve of of this house
bill well point of point point of
information Mr
chair what's happened here is that joh
has
threatened a representative and in my
nine years in this in this uh work that
we've been doing here I have never seen
anybody
threatened with uh a public disposure
like he did to representative luno and
to me
indirectly because we disagreed with his
approach to how he runs his university
and what his university was doing so I
think that that is relevant here as it
relates to the Integrity of of his
institution in
threatening a sitting representative Mr
Miler the only thing I threatened as you
say is to publicly but a public
statement I made no personal threats of
any kind I only said that I was going to
rebut in public the statements publicly
made by Mr luno that's all that I said
Mr myor that is that's not the way we
took it you do not deal you do not deal
with
representatives in a threatening fashion
if you disagree with them I only said I
was going to disagree with them and in
public and I do not see how a public
disagreement with a public statement
constitutes a threat as I've said if you
thought my tone objectionable I can only
say that I feel sorry that you felt that
way that was not at all my intention Mr
chair uh yes I'm going to interject
right now and um this conversation could
go on forever here and we're not going
to resolve it at this moment here in in
the education committee um there might
be another Avenue for this and I suspect
if represent luno wants to choose that
Avenue he may do so but at this point in
time we're dealing specifically with
this bill and we have other people who
would like to testify and we're already
beyond the half hour we had allocated to
this bill Mr chair yes um u in a on an
earlier Bill I'd asked you a question
which you deferred to um um members for
the Department that never showed up to
testify but I'd like to know if members
from the Department are going to be here
this we have one other person that's
here to testify it be Lori
Alden and she's representing herself we
have no other folks here
to testify uh to the committee today we
have some that have you know we had one
neutral for support and one
opposed I believe we do have um Mr
Appleby here okay Steve applebe has by
has uh raised his hand I see that but
um well we're gonna uh Lori Alden is at
the at the top here in of the queue we
should follow the order um if there are
no more questions at this time for Dr
Olsen we will move on to the next person
Alden good morning fellow Granite
Staters thank you for the opportunity to
speak about House Bill 513 relative to
the degree granting authority of Signum
University I'm Lori Alden a resident of
planfield New Hampshire after I
graduated from Signum University I
became an Adjunct professor of English
at River Valley Community College based
in Claremont Home of the famous
Claremont decision where teachers who
are excited enthusiastic can make a
world of difference in New
Hampshire in January of 2012 I began
taking courses at Signum while I raised
two middle school children attended my
mother in the last year of her life
supported my police officer wife and
performed my halftime job I desperately
needed new thoughts new ways to keep my
brain stimulated and new ways to advance
myself I have been where my community
college students are Signum University
through its board of directors exposed
me to world class professors on the edge
of our field training me in exacting
habits of mind and discernment I studied
great writers from the bwolf poet to
contemporary authors I deepened my
skills of literary research reader
response inquiry analysis synthesis and
above all professional academic
communication of my findings and I bring
these skills to my students from
Claremont Charlestown Keane and Lebanon
who need to inquire into history analyze
their chemistry lab findings synthesize
the learning of multiple courses into
one nursing career path and communicate
clearly at their place of
work I'm just a mom from planfield but
because of Signum University I got to
develop cuttingedge standards of digital
Humanities research other Scholars used
the tools that I developed and I made
them freely accessible in the internet
because that's how I was taught the best
Scholars strive to educate on the global
stage Signum has always devoted itself
to full accessibility from the Nob
building lowcost infrastructure to the
global reach of the internet Signum
strives to be open to everyone with a
desire to learn in this modest but but
active corner of Academia rural
residents of Coos County folks with
Mobility impairment and even tired
sandwich generation moms from planfield
can challenge ourselves better ourselves
as long as we have even a public library
with internet access I myself was a work
study student and prepared teaching
materials for my professors to use in
our online live class lectures and our
small group discussions
when this pandemic hit our nation my
students did not lose one iota of
educational time in my classroom because
I have a decade of experience in a vital
online education program which makes the
email correspondence schools of the
1990s look like the correspondence
schools of the
1880s through the Community College I've
opened a Writing Center called writer
space at River Valley a free place for
writers of all kinds to encourage one
another and get work done writer space
is now virtual with writers from all
over the country and I welcome you all
to join me for quiet work time in a
manner which combats the loneliness of
our safer atome times go to the river
valley website click on community and
you'll find writer space Signum
University is a great resource for New
Hampshire residents and fellow Learners
all over the world the rigorous
standards of online education which the
state has learned to implement and
assess Mak Signum approval an excellent
move for the state as a whole the high
quality of Signum University's online
educational programs will be a signal to
our Global neighbors that authorization
from the state of New Hampshire means
thorough vetting high standards and
agree a degree which can be held up
against any other master of arts in
language and literature across the globe
thank you for this opportunity and I'm
pleased to answer any questions here or
respond to email inquiries thank you
very much for your testimony are there
any
questions not seeing any hands up or or
here uh next person thank you very much
Lori uh next individual to speak would
Appleby
Stephen if if you're undo your mute
button there got
it no no no can't hear you yeah I hit
your mute or
unmute thank you I think I'm good now um
I apologize my zoom closed exactly as
you were queuing me yeah um good morning
representatives and thank you uh Steven
applebe director division of educator
support and higher education at the
Department of Education and I'm here to
just answer any questions with regards
to the approval process that Signum has
gone through with the higher education
commission thank you very much Stephen
are there any questions represent luno
thank you very much Mr chair and thank
you very much Mr applebe for um for um
for being here uh this afternoon um on
um January 10th 2020 during a f meeting
of the Jo or just prior to a meeting of
the joint fiscal committee uh in the lob
I uh handed a copy of the aforementioned
email to commissioner edbl and uh I was
wondering if uh if at either of the um
the meeting of the higher education
committee back in October 2020 which was
referenced earlier uh where they um I
guess
reordain um the um recommendation for
Signum or um just in the last few weeks
with the meeting of the State Board of
Education um uh to uh to approve uh some
of Signum uh programs for New Hampshire
High School uh graduation credit if to
either of those um committees the higher
educ or commissions the higher educ
higher education commission or and State
Board of Education if they were made
aware of um of the email we were
referring to
earlier thank you for the question
representative luno I have no knowledge
either
way the answer to that question I
apologize I I have not read the email
and I do not know if it was shared with
either of those bodies okay followup Mr
chair yes um um do you in in your
opinion Mr applebe do you feel that
either um dick gustofson or any of the
members of the higher education
committee or any of the members of the
State Board of Education um um would
would want to have information as it
relates to ethics and integrity of the
matters before
them thank you again for the question
and um with with all due respect to the
question representative luno um I am
reminded um at times especially by my
spouse that um I don't get paid for my
opinions so um I would uh respectfully
uh not offer an opinion as I really
don't have one on the matter um I'm
looking at the facts as I said and here
to answer any factual questions
regarding the process that Signum
University uh went through to gain their
approval as well as the process they
went through to then um be reapproved uh
through the end of the year so and a
final followup on that Mr chair I'd like
to interject again uh we are talking
about a program here we're talking about
authorization of Signum um I think it's
unfair to ask another individual how
dick gusterson May uh feel towards
something um I'd like to try and keep uh
where you're going out of the
conversation here and remain on task
here dealing with the bill that we have
in front of us go ahead rebon luno okay
thanks thanks very much final question
um on this earlier today we um we were
discussing a bill that considered um
various um um crimes and misdemeanors
that would keep uh an educator out of
being hired by a school district seeing
as uh this organization has now been
approved um for um uh for issuing
graduation credit to Granite State High
School students do you feel that um that
anything that could be evidence of of a
crime that was um or of certain criminal
activity that was in the in the control
of the department um um should have been
should be presented to the State
Board um thank you again for I'm I'm
going to interject again here um this is
not relevant to this particular Bill and
uh rson luno if you want to pursue
something on a side go ahead but we're
not going to do it through this
committee and we're not going to use
people are test in for the purpose of
where you're going I'm done Mr chair
thank you I have a question represent
Miler uh when we were considering uh
this uh school last year there were 13
outstanding issues that they had not
complied with uh with the recommendation
from the commission are you aware
whether or not those 13 have been
complied with yes um thank you
representative Milo for the question um
and I would say
um there are always recommendations for
every R review that the higher IDE
commission conducts of any college
program in our state or from out of
state and so having 13
recommendations is not an unreasonable
or unusual number and they have in fact
um met all of those recommendations
which was one of the bases for extending
their approval through the end of this
year thank
you thank thank you very much
uh uh Mr applebe uh it looks like we've
that okay we'll have one more Mr Olsen
ahead hi sorry now I just wanted to
offer uh to provide further information
about the 13 recommendations question
and I wanted to clarify
that when I said when I referred to the
recommendations that were given in order
for us to make progress towards them and
our second year and those 13
recommendations which the higher
education commission had deemed we had
made so much progress towards that they
delayed our uh our further review by an
additional year those are the 13
recommendations I was referring to thank
you very much um we will we do rep
Hopson do we have any further folks
online okay we've had all those that
have asked to testify uh complete uh
done and so at this time I'm going to
close this
hearing uh 5:13 and uh break for
lunch how long Rick it starts up at one
o'clock thank you thank
you thank you everybody let them um
members you can stay on the call it'll
continue to be open if you just want to
video well she's going to keep this
thing running but I want this room
turned
off
okay
right
all
Arthur any any
basketball yeah I can't find a place to
play but but my kids gave me a an
outdoor hoop to put up in the spring so
maybe there's some hope how the wheels
doing they're fine it's my shoulder see
I got I got bone on bone in the shoulder
and arthritis so it's taking 50,000
shots course of my lifetime that did it
how many of those did you hit H about
4,000
[Laughter]
yeah just don't try to dunk it art I
okay okay can people hear me out there
in the
yes we can Rick okay thank you very much
uh we're about ready to go ahead and
start this afternoon's uh hearings uh
just uh one uh piece of information for
everybody does everybody out there know
how to raise your hand using the
technology on the machine oh yes very
good Mr Woodcock I can do that too but
uh there there is that little yellow
hand down there yes if you hit that um
at least on my screen I don't know if
yours looks the same it
should um just raise it like that you've
got
it at the I don't
see I don't see it I don't see it on
mine no problem right next to
participant share screen record raise
hand I don't have a raiseed hand I don't
have raised hand it may appear on your
participant panel so make sure that
you've clicked on participants at the
bottom of your screen a panel should pop
up and you may see raise hand at the
bottom of that panel y got
it okay I'd like to go ahead Jen are are
we H recording yep you're good to
go e we have
ech is everybody on mute oh there we go
okay okay so we are recording so I can
close
that
so uh with that uh we're continuing this
uh session for the
day um we're looking at HB
442 that's relative to penalties for a
school's failure to file Department of
Education
reports and with that we'll open up the
hearing and uh representative Cordell
you are the prime sponsor of that bill
uh you have the floor uh thank you very
much Mr chairman for the record uh
cordelli representing Tu BAU multi sin
which is the beautiful Lakes Region and
uh this is really a pretty simple piece
of legislation that worked on with the
Department of Education um due to uh
occasional problems the department has
had uh getting uh information from our
local districts uh you can remember a
couple of years ago we had a similar
problem with um getting emergency plans
from uh districts and it wasn't until um
there was the threat of uh uh
withholding of funds that the U
emergency plans uh suddenly started to
appear um this bill amends current
statute related to the requirements for
districts to report uh information to
the
department uh the current statute
however does not includ include Charter
Public Schools in a number of areas and
uh that has uh occasionally presented
problems uh going through the bill uh
just to highlight those areas um in
section one on on the first page uh
chartered public schools are added along
with the provision that failing to
comply with the financial reporting for
two consecutive years uh would allow the
commissioner to request that the State
Board of Education revoke their
Charter I think that this might um
encourage them to get those reports in
on
time um in section two just down um uh
about the middle of the page line 15 uh
with statistical
reports uh these reports are used to
calculate a deily average membership uh
Staffing information
Etc um this
new language adds uh a new report and
that is prior year safety uh
information and uh also provides for
other reports that the department might
feel are necessary to comply with uh
federal and state law and here again we
also add chartered Public Schools as
well as non-public schools in this
requirement uh starting on line 25 uh
Section 1 a uh additional reporting
requirements are added for non-public
schools along here with the penalty also
of U uh having their Charter or uh
approval revoked by the department um
and the state court if
necessary on section three over on page
two uh we modify the extension provision
for subu reports to specify that a delay
that does not impact State calculations
uh in uh using those statistic reports
um allows for further extensions um for
getting the reports in in section four
uh beginning on line 11 I believe it is
uh the
uh chapter on Charter Schools is updated
to reflect that failure to report as we
have discussed as well just for
consistency uh purposes that need to be
inserted in the charter school chapter
as well and then finally on uh section
five on line
17 uh we get into the uh monetary
reporting and throughout 198 4D school
districts are in statute and HP 442 adds
chartered public schools here
again
occasionally the failure to
report has caused problems and it's a
very small number of instances um that I
believe the department has a spokesman
here who will uh probably uh be able to
refer to uh but this will help the
department in fulfilling their statutory
requirements um and I uh will have my
testimony there and be glad to take any
questions and U also uh refer some
questions to the department thank you
very much uh representative cordelli are
there qu questions for the
representative Linda Tanner Linda Tanner
yes hi uh thank you very much Mr chair
uh and thank you uh representative
cordelli I was wondering and I I didn't
get receed the copies of the bills so
I'm I don't have the numbered sides I
just printed out from my my computer but
I was wondering in section 1A uh where
you've done a crossover of average daily
membership in attendance fall enrollment
and teacher staff census why exactly was
that crossed out for charter schools and
for uh non-public
schools
um you can ask the department more about
that but I'm not sure if the nonpublic
schools are required to submit average
daily
membership
are are they uh followup please yes are
they required for the rest of the things
the uh School emergency plan the yes uh
state they're they're required for those
other things I'm sorry that's what is
added in this section yes the the
department wants that information from
the non-public schools um has that been
required of them
before um I don't believe in statute it
has been required of them
thank
you uh thank you very much uh
representative Woodcock thank you Mr
chairman represent cell just a quick
question on line 17 in the uh
statistical reporting just curious why
they exed out August one where that date
may have given schools an opportunity to
dates um I think probably the U uh uh
young lady from the Department of
Education might have a better answer to
that than I
do
okay okay thank you very much uh
representative Woodcock the young lady
they're talking about is Caitlyn Davis
and I I think you're probably familiar
with
Caitlyn I'm sure the answer I do have
the answer um well thank you very much
for the record I'm Caitlyn Davis I a
director at the Department of Education
um and we actually had reached out um
from the Department of Education to
representative cordelli to ask him to
co-sponsor this bill for the department
or to sponsor we are a sponsor um for
the Department because of some
challenges that we've experienced with a
very select few schools over the last
few years um and we had actually asked
for this bill to be sponsored last year
too and unfortunately um with everything
that had happened it got a little
derailed um through that process um
there are the reason we asked for this
legislation is there are a few schools
and by a few I mean about a handful that
continually do not report information on
time and then as a result of that we are
held up at the state to from reporting
various federal and state reports that
we need to submit like average daily
membership cost per pupil teacher
average salaries and whatnot so this
language already exists on the the books
for district Public Schools um we very
very rarely will actually trigger that
language we only had one school for
example this past year that failed to um
failed to report their doe2 on time or
to file an request for an extension
because the department of education
allows them to file an ex request
request for extension through November
6th and so what we did was we um then
notified them that we would be holding
any additional state Aid paid after
November 6th keep in mind the deadline
was September 1st and had that school
just filed an extension we would have
paid that school so that was really the
the issue with that we do have a select
few Charter Schools just like the
traditional public schools that have you
know we have the same challenge with and
unfortunately we don't have that kind of
ability to hold the funding so we do
have to continue to pay them even though
they haven't reported extremely
important financial information to the
department including the doe2 and
potentially audited financial statements
which would allow the Department of
Education to really ensure that the
schools are appropriately using that
funding in the correct manner so that's
really why we as asked for that
legislation to be filed um a clar
clarification for the August 1 um so the
August 1 we that August 1 deadline is a
little bit confusing because some of
those things that need to be reported
actually need to be reported sooner than
that um because they go into larger
calculations and some of those um
deadlines they have specific parts so
the August 1 deadline while it's called
out in law people are saying or people
often say is that August 1 required the
first submission to the Department of
Education or the final submission
because schools submit data review data
um you know cleared anomalies and look
you know um do D data validation so the
August first is just kind of a confusing
point the Department of Education every
single year provides numerous trainings
for schools about deadlines we published
deadlines on law I mean sorry on our uh
deadlines um on our website and make
sure to communicate that with schools of
what what the expectations are so we
don't think the August 1 would actually
be an issue at all um it's just you know
if something needs to be changed the
August first deadline actually is to
it's a um it doesn't really add
sufficient time for the Department of
Education to be able to do some of the
um reporting that we need to do at the
beginning of the year so um the we have
kind of artificially moved that up um
right now um and and we do need it to be
a little bit earlier the last point is
with the non-public schools um so yes
the non-public schools are not required
to submit um teacher salaries um or some
of the other information that is listed
right there I actually don't have the
bill pulled up in front of me because I
don't zoom and that on both my screens
um but the intent of the bill was not to
require anybody to to submit any new
information or change anything in the in
the way they're submitting the data all
of the data that is called out in this
law is already in a law someplace else
um and that includes the safety report
so non-public schools are required to
submit it um but we have had some
challenges with some non-public schools
in the past and that's why we um added
that language and here want to clar
verify that they are actually required
to submit it because it's a little bit
confusing when it looks when you look at
the law and it says right here what
they're required to submit and versus
another area of the law that talks about
the report and says non-public schools
are required to submit it so that's kind
of we were trying to clarify that with
that any other questions for
me uh yes uh Caitlyn I have one question
for you this Rick
lad I'll take M so you can hear me uh
are some school districts requiring
prior to the submitt of their doe 25
form to have that form
audited and if they do so is there
enough time from the end of the fiscal
year to you know the deadline that you
set for them to get those audited before
they come to
you so the doe 25 deadline is a chicken
in the egg sort of situation yes some
school districts have the doe 25 um
prepared by their Auditors actually the
number seems to increase each year um
but it is not a state requirement for it
to be audited how and and the September
1 deadline would be a challenge if they
were going to have their auditor prepare
it because um it's a pretty tight
deadline with wrapping up the end of the
school year which ends on June 30th and
and having financial statements prepared
however the do25 is a required document
um by the Department of Education and
the ra for tax rate setting so the
Department of Education has to review
the doe2 give the the appropriate
information to the Department of Revenue
and then they use that information for
tax rate setting so if you were to push
it back any further the Department of
Revenue wouldn't be able to set the tax
rates in an appropriate time period
which they usually try to get most of
them out in the middle of October and
early
November thank you Caitlyn I I see that
representative Le has his hand up thank
you Mr chairman and um thank you uh Miss
Davis uh for for taking a question here
and I apologize I'm new to the committee
so I don't know all the ins and outs of
things here but I want to follow up on
just what uh representative Tanner asked
before so I'm looking at line 25 section
1A where it go non-public schools shall
submit and it eliminates average daily
membership in attendance fall enrollment
and teacher staff census that was all in
that is all in current statute um so if
that is eliminated um do those reports
still have to be made by non-public then
so um I think that the part that's a
little bit confusing is the paragraph
above it now adds non-public schools
into it and it lists that
information whereas this one right here
actually um talks about the other
specific reports that only non-public
schools are required to submit thank you
I see it thank you thank you uh
representative Tanner you have your hand
up um I should take it down I I had this
same question as representative Lei that
it looked like that the private schools
were already submitting reports on a
average daily membership Etc and that it
had changed to General statistics of
non-public schools and I'm just
wondering if that's where the change was
to um take out specific uh
requirements so I guess I'll ask that of
Caitlyn
again um so Jack General statistics so
that's actually a report that we use um
that's like the name of a report that we
have in our system and so the state
state seclusion report the general fall
collection those are all the names of
actual reports whereas before when we
were talking about average daily
membership and follow those were just
kind of more specific type things uh
follow-up please yes you may um so what
exactly is in the general statistics of
non-public school report I don't don't
have a copy of it right here in front of
me they can certainly send the committee
a copy of
that thank you very much uh represent
Miler uh thank you Mr chairman and thank
you Caitlyn for being with us today
could you remind us again what is in the
safety
report um so Diana Fenton is on the
phone I believe and she may be better
equipped to answer that report as she
reviews it I don't know if we could I
could phone a friend for that one Zuma
friend that's that's that's okay if you
don't if you don't know that's that's
fine I so I just don't have it memorized
I can certainly send the committee of
the committee a copy of that report
you representative luno I don't know
yeah we're we're hold on a second we're
trying to see if uh Diana Fenton is
available or whether she wants to
answer promoted she has been
Lieutenant okay uh in the inter room
let's have representative
luno thanks very much Mr chair and um
and uh and thanks very much uh Miss
Davis and and Miss Fenton for being with
us this afternoon this could be a tossup
question to to either one of um uh you
but but there there is some change
and this relates to what representative
Tanner and representative Lei were
asking about too but but change in the
use of the words District school and
Education Agency and I was wondering um
if that's a material change or if those
three um terms I mean are they different
can they be used
interchangeably um and in in particular
you you'll see how that changes in um
section two Roman one
um where we where we go from public
education agency now to calling it um a
non-public Education Agency and a public
two you've got private schools but
there's there's a area where it goes
from from District to schools and I was
just wondering if that how material that
is
okay uh anybody have an answer to that
or Di has her hand up let's see where we
go there uh welcome uh attorney
Fenton oh good afternoon and I always
cringe when people call me attorney
Fenton it just means I'm in
[Laughter]
trouble go for
it if you could bring me up to speed I
was multitasking at at the time I got
promoted
um is it to is it to answer
representative Luna's question of
material one of the one of the questions
which we had here uh is uh the school
emergency operation plan it was dealing
with safety what are some of the
know the school emergency plan that
would not fall within my world I'm I'm
not sadly I'm not familiar with what
that would be and I don't know yeah I
I'm sorry I think I thought the question
was about the school safety report which
if you want I've have now since pulled
it up on my screen and I can share it I
or I think if you just review some of
the contents is what I was concerned
about just the flavor of the survey
right
so the school safety survey um it has a
variety of Statistics in it um the
number of seclusion reports rest stain
reports um from by and it's by school
it's a very comprehensive report um and
it's submitted by every school public
non-public and District school in the
state uh in charter
school um so I'm opening it right now
and I can kind of through it um so the
the report every single year um Diana
it's presented to the State Board of
Education that's correct right you
usually do that report with
Rich yes yeah um and so so it has so I
said restraint some invest any
information on restraints and seclusion
that's being investigated um and it it
kind of goes into the detail of you know
did the the restraints um result in
bodily harm Serious injury um and then
it good kind of same types of questions
about seclusion the number
investigations with seclusion then
there's questions about
harassment and the types of harassment
um that are being reported by the school
um you know if they were related to
gender sexual orientation race and color
or national origin disability physical
characteristics um and so then it it
goes through all of that um and then we
have a we have a bullying
section and it talks about you know the
types of bullying that is occurring so
was it cyber bullying bullying of any
kind um is the are the bullying based on
gender sexual orientation race color
national origin
disability um and then were the bullying
incidentes singly uh single or were they
significant was there a pattern um was
there did it include physical abuse or
harm Dam damage to property um use of
emotional or social alienizer in school
operations and then there's a variety of
other um types of things that we collect
including student
discipline um the the the types of
discipline including suspensions and
expulsions okay um keep going I don't
know that that's good enough thank you
very much yeah it it sounds very
thorough yes extremely thorough um and
it is on the doe website if anybody is
you know interested in taking a look at
that there's information for the last
three years for every school in the
state of New
Hampshire are there any further
questions for Caitlyn Davis or for Diana
Fenton uh dougl I see your hand up well
mine's still out there oh okay I was
going to follow
up go ahead B sorry go ahead represent
luno no no the the the question was
asked basically the um the the the
changes back in um section two Roman one
and section three Roman 4 of the use of
the terms District school and Education
Agency just wondering if those are you
know when it talks about like in section
three Roman four that the department can
grant a waiver um or a 30-day extension
to a school district
and now it's being changed from that's
struck um School District City or public
Academy and being replaced by public
school chartered public school or
non-public school is is is there a
material difference in in that and then
the term Education Agency I think is is
um is used up in um in um oh section two
Roman one and uh just wondering if
that's um you know does that make a
difference and what's the difference
terms Diana do you want to take this
one well I think it was I think Caitlyn
I could probably answer it together I
think it was to address that we wanted
it to apply clearly to these
entities um which my understanding is
currently it does it does not so I think
school district has been
expanded um and then the city Republic
Academy I think those are kind of older
terms is my understanding of the statute
more yeah so we the public Academy
really refers to there's three schools
in the state that are considered
Publicis um but they're not run by a
specific School Board um for as far as
interchangeably at the top with the use
of Education Agency I think that's I
think that's really just where the um
term was chosen to be inserted for to
add non-public and Charter Schools um
when we the the last part where it talks
about the Department's authority to hold
payments that part um we had an
interpretation of the law at the time
and they said the that it was not broad
enough and because it specifically said
public school um sorry Public District
or or public Academy that the
Department's authority to hold payment
did not also extend to a public charter
school in this specific instance so
that's why we added the word charter
school or non-public school into
there so quick followup on that Mr chair
yes um so our I I I guess I'm still um
fumbling around a little bit with the
with the term educ ation
agency um I know it was it was a new
term to me when I first got on a school
board and it was referred and our school
district was referred to as the local
Education Agency the Lea and and I seem
to recall that that had a different
level of
responsibility um for certain things
than maybe um like a charter school and
so uh I guess is every school in
education agency and our non-public
schools education agencies and do they
take on additional responsibilities
because they're education agencies
instead of just
schools I think we would have to look at
the definition of Education Agency in
state law so we should actually do that
probably as part of this bill um as far
as Federal funding is concerned Federal
funding is used throughout federal law
to talk about Education Agency and it's
usually the person that's receiving the
funding for the V variety of different
federal grants so for title one for
example a charter school would be
considered an Lea a local Education
Agency no no different than a district
uh District school would be because they
both receive the funding and are
expected to say to follow the same
responsibilities and requirements of the
grant um there are certainly grants that
don't go to all local education agencies
um for example a um uh title uh title
five which is TW or TW title 4 a rather
21st Century it only goes to very
specific school districts um and so that
those would be leas for the purpose of
that specific Grant and that specific
requirement so essentially I think
providing the Education Services
required in that Grant but we can
certainly look at the definition of both
of those and maybe clarify that that
might not be a bad idea okay thank
thanks so much Kaitlyn thank thank you
uh yeah represent you did have your hand
up is it down
now uh Mr chairman I just wanted to
again just be be clear on this because
I'm I'm new to this so a non-public
Education Agency and then we have
non-public school are they the same
simple mean I think they're being
interchange
interchangeably used in this law
currently so I maybe we should Define
them for the purpose of the specific law
um but so the word Education Agency was
already in the law we just added the
words nonpublic and charges to it and
down below the word Education Agency did
not exist so that was not added right no
thank you I I I think your idea of
clarification might be a good
one thank you okay further hands uh
represent leus I just want to make sure
that I understand the section under
nonpublic schools those are things that
are already asked for or are there any
new ones those are all things that are
already asked for and um just for the
committee purpose I just got
clarification from a staff member um on
what is in the education statistics and
that's just general information so
that's basically when we ask a school to
review that their name is such and such
school and their address is this and
their principal is this and their add
you know their phone number so that's
the general information on the school in
our database um so that's what's
contained in that fall report but we did
not ask um we did not use this bill to
expand any reporting requirements that
were not already in
law thank you thank you very much are
there any further
questions of the
department not seeing any hands uh thank
you very much both to Diane and to
Caitlyn thank you um next person up is
margerie
Porter
there okay well she she's not testifying
should be a no as far as testifying so
okay um going on down I don't see any
other folks that I have that wanted to
is there anybody in the attendee list
that we missed no okay I think uh we are
at the base of where we are here as far
as testimony today on
442 um what we have here is those that I
had on my list right here we had uh two
people opposed two people supportive
three people supportive and one
neutral
um so there that's where we are on that
one so thank you very much to everybody
we will close this hearing and get ready
schools uh I'd like to to have uh
representa cordelli the prime
sponsor uh he can have the floor uh
present the Bill thank you Mr chairman
U record cordelli represen bur b b and
sandwich in the beautiful Lakes
Region um Innovation
schools uh we have often heard Charter
Schools being referred to as
Laboratories of innovation
uh it's basically in Statute in uh 194
B1 uh their statement of
purpose is and I quote to exempt charter
schools from State statutes and rules
other than where specified to provide
Innovative learning and teaching in a
unique
environment uh the question how do we
allow traditional public schools to
609 establishes a process by which
districts can request and obtain waivers
from administrative rules from the state
board and Innovative schools are not new
uh Massachusetts Maine Colorado Etc um
all have programs to allow innovation in
their Public
Schools according to the Center for
Reinventing public education there were
actually 14 States
and some waivers even excuse me some
states even allow waivers from laws in
addition to wavers uh which we are not
doing uh I will point out that some
talking points have been passed around
that this bill was given to me by Alec
as model
legislation uh we heard that charge last
time I submitted this bill it's
untrue it's a talking point the truth is
is that I have looked
at legislation from many of these states
talk to people in Colorado in their
Department of Education and work
primarily from the legislation in
Colorado um I want to make that clear
because the point doesn't seem to be
getting through to
people uh the New Hampshire
administrative rules are quite a volume
the table of content contents is 24
pages long by
itself uh I'd like to go through some
sections of this bill to allow you to
see um more about Innovative schools and
how they are
approved um in the definition sections
we have definitions for both Innovative
school and Innovation Zone which would
allow uh for a school district and its
entirety or even multiple districts uh
zone in uh
section uh
1942 a public school May submit to its
local board inovation plan the local
board is involved directly with approval
of any
plan um any uh joint districts May uh
apply to their local school boards to
create an Innovative zone so every
school board involved is in uh involved
plan over on page two we get into uh
what is in the Innovation
plan and it must include a number of
things uh the mission statement of the
school description of the innovations
that the uh public school would like to
implement and
importantly the administrative rules
from which the schools are requesting a
waiver there would be a listing of
programs and policies and documents
affected by the uh identified
Innovations and
waiver um going on to page three uh each
plan for creating in inovation zone may
include a number of things and that was
specified uh here and that would include
things like uh an estimate of the
economies of scale uh description of how
the Innovations would benefit the public
school uh
Etc and each School Board would
consider uh Innovations in areas such as
curriculum academic standards assessment
uh
accountability uh the way services are
provided
excuse me um as well as performance
expectation and school
governance it doesn't stop at the local
school
board state board approval is required
going on to page four the local school
board would submit uh their Innovations
plans first to the department for review
and comment the department would respond
with any suggested uh suggested changes
or additions to the plan back to the
local board and then the local board
would submit the plan to the state board
for review the state board has to hold a
public hearing on the
plan uh the state board has 60 days to
uh review that plan and either approve
or reject the
plan uh written explanation of the
decision is required to be presented to
board
and I want to be clear as we pointed out
on page four that each district shall
continue to be subject to all laws and
rules that are not waved by the state
board it's not a blanket waiver that uh
is provided for
here and in terms of accountability uh
down the bottom of page four uh the
State Board uh reviews the uh state me
the Innovation plans every two
years
and that is based on a local Board
review of the plan and whether they
believe that the uh Innovation plan is
working and that the uh improvements
that were uh originally specified are
being
realized this uh Department of Education
reviews the results of the local board
plan the local board May at any time if
they feel that the their plan is not
working revise the plan or notify the
state board that they wish wish to uh
terminate their um Innovation plan and
um uh their request for waivers likewise
the department if they feel that the uh
Innovation plan is not working and
results are not there uh they may revoke
the U approval of the
plan and uh there is a requirement does
the State Board excuse me the Department
of Education uh provide an annual report
on uh any school that has an innovation
uh plan accepted and you'll see on the
bottom of page five a number of the
areas that are required uh in the
department um report to the legislature
so the
intent is that we give
flexibility to traditional Public
Schools uh I think that it is important
given what has gone on this past year um
changes that are coming down the road
um in all of Education to give schools
flexibility on how they respond and how
they can innovate uh isn't that what we
all want we want schools to be able to
innovate and
improve the provision for waivers from
administrative rules provides that
Schools the some opponents of this have
um complained that uh the workers um
will not produce change and um will only
uh hurt Public Schools but we have
Provisions in here for local public
schools review the department review
State Board review and at any point if
it is seen that the results are not
there program isn't working uh the
program can be
terminated uh but we need to help all of
our kids kids and through
Innovation I think is one way we can do
that thank
you thank you very much representative
cordelli are there questions for
representative
cordelli representa leas yeah I was just
wondering thank you representative Celli
I was wondering if you could give an
do a school do in terms of what might be
an innovation and and a waiver that is
uh maybe in terms of curriculum um you
know we see public EXC me public
chartered schools uh innovate in terms
of U uh their uh could be anything in
terms of curriculum standards an area of
focus um uh I'd even um talked about a
charge school being started in my area
um for agriculture they would have a
different school year so there are all
kinds of uh administrative rules on
these areas and uh we just want to give
schools flexibility um and I think uh
someone from the Department uh also
might be available to talk about uh what
are in thetive rules thank you uh I see
representative Ellison has his hand up
thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative Celli taking my question
uh my question concerns 194 E2 Roman
numeral 3 h no I'm sorry yes H that's
the the part that talks about waving any
provision of a collective bargaining
agreement if the local school board had
recently signed a collective bargaining
agreement with the teachers and had
agreed to certain wages salaries and
work conditions could they then turn
around and decide they're going to ask
for a waiver of that collective
bargaining agreement for people who were
teaching at this new Innovative school
um maybe direct me uh I didn't catch
where you were looking uh it's 194 E2 uh
Roman numeral
3 H bottom of page
yes right
if right it's in the U the plan um uh
has to include programs or documents
that would be affected by The Innovation
um they would have in the plan they
would have outline if the requested
waiver or innovation plan did affect any
bargaining agreement we're not talking
about getting a waiver from a bargaining
agreement or labor agreement we're
talking about um just uh that has to be
included in the plan that is presented
to the local school board anything that
might be impacted by the
request followup Mr chairman yes
represent uh then going back to the
example I used before uh if if a school
district chose to pay teachers in an
Innovative program less than it was
paying the regular school teachers under
the collective bargaining agreement they
waiver I I think that uh if the uh
School administration was requesting
going back into negotiation with the
Union that it would be included in the
plan that that was part of the plan that
they were going to renegotiate negotiate
an
agreement it does not give uh the
district part blanch in terms of um
modifying a labor agreement it's just
notifying the school board that um part
of the plan would be um looking at a
labor
agreement I I don't see um uh instances
U where that would happen uh but uh it
would have to be provided for and
thank
you uh representative uh
Mullen you your hand
up I do thank you Mr chairman I
appreciate your uh being attentive to
that uh so thank you representative
cordelli I am on page two Roman numeral
three which is line five the section
that says each Innovation plan may
include the following information so uh
just as a general comment I um am
affected by how many times the word may
appears in the document as opposed to
shall um just because we know that when
we're talking about reporting things out
that there's a world of difference
between May and shell but in this
particular section um I'm looking at
the things that the the list of things
that may be waved as part of this
process this Innovation School process
um Innovations in school Staffing
curriculum assessment scheduling
financial and other resources faculty
recruitment employment evaluation
compensation programs policies
operational documents the length of the
school day the length of the school year
year promotion and graduation policies
I'm just following down in that section
plan I is it possible that somebody in
designing such an Innovative school
would be requesting
that all of those things be waved
or a preponderance of those things I I
guess I'm I I guess I'm wondering how we
determine where we're giving up the
pieces that the State Board of Education
have determined our part of an essential
and adequate
education I I'm I'm just wondering where
the where the uh the breaks are if you
will on how much the breaks are four
different places there with are five
School
administration Local School Board uh
Department of uh education public
hearings and the State Board of
Education at every step in the process
there are breaks that can be
applied could I'm just gonna follow up
on that if I if I I'm sorry go ahead uh
so when you say that that they would
apply breaks would that be just in the
form of denying a request for something
to be
waved uh the uh included in the bill is
the provision for the Department of
Education to review um an innovation
plan that is submitted by a local board
uh the department can make
recommendations for changes or
alterations uh back to the local
board okay thank
you thank you uh representative I'm
going to scroll across my screen right
woodcock
thank you chairman lab but I was I was
at the end of the line I'll let
represent Milo go first that's okay okay
Mel uh thank you uh Mr chairman uh a
couple things first of all I hope that
the uh title of this bill is not denying
that there's uh Innovations going on in
schools on a daily basis in this state
and that's why we rank in the top five
in the country the two questions I have
for clarification uh representative
cordelli is this
uh first of all as I've looked at
Innovation schools one of the things one
of the pieces of legislation that I see
common in in the language is the ability
of the staff in a particular school to
vote on whether or not they want to
become an Innovative school and in most
cases it's about 60% if 60% of the staff
vote on it then it's fine if not then
it's denied so that's one the one
question I have is why wasn't there a
vote in your bill uh regarding the
incumbent staff of that particular
school that's question one question two
is is there an implication here that in
the Innovative School said it's possible
to hire non-certified teachers to be in
that Innovative school so those two are
my two questions thank
you um first of all I I think that
um the onus is put on the school ad
School administration and the local
school board uh to come up and approve
the
plan uh the local school board are the
local Representatives um of the people
and I'm sure that uh all School
administration uh takes uh staff uh into
consideration uh in terms of your second
question was if you could repeat that
please certified staff oh the second
question is whether or not you can hire
non-certified staff to be in an
Innovative school or do they have to be
certified
teachers
uh the uh bill is not uh referring
specifically to certified or
non-certified staff but generally to
administrative rules so uh
conceivably um there are many
administrative rules that could be
considered U for wer
request um uh I know we've heard um
discussion about uh uh the need for U uh
nurses or Librarians if there's a
library across the street uh there might
be waivers uh requested there um there's
all sorts of possibilities but the idea
is to uh allow schools to have some
flexibility
with the breaks that we've talked about
all the way up the line to the State
Board of
Education so the answer that to my
second question is
yes there's nothing in the bill to
prohibit that's okay thank you that's
all I needed thank you very
much okay next in the queue I guess
that's you
Steve thank you represent I appreciate
that represent qu thank thank you for
bringing this forward I have I have a
couple questions and and represent Miler
caught one of them already so and as did
representative Mullen uh you talked
about the flexibility that this program
gives to Public Schools um like many on
the board including those sitting around
the table down there where you are today
um I've been an administrator in Maine
New Hampshire and Massachusetts all at
the high school level and nothing
precluded me in any of those three
states uh of bringing uh Innovation and
flexibility within the curricula for the
program in my school so I'm trying to
Sugg why figure out why this actually is
a needed bill um it's up to the
leadership in each school to do that I
would think I mean nothing stop that
that's that's question one if I and save
time I'll ask question two and three
secondly when you were describing the
the Traditional School flexibility you
kept on using the word chat school and I
was trying to to find why that was the
example instead of innovative school and
thirdly under the top of the bill where
it says FN and L what is the FN and L
actually going to cost us those three
there's three questions there Mr
me uh the LBA was unable to uh complete
uh fiscal analysis I don't know if it's
going to cost uh the state anything
uh I I'm not sure where it would cost uh
the state uh to Grant a uh waiver
but in terms of U
Innovation we always hear about Charter
Schools being Laboratories of
information and one reason is because um
because they don't have to follow all
the administrative regular Public
Schools do if if that's not the case um
you know I I'll stand corrected but I've
always heard that argument being made
um so I think that uh giving flexibility
to Public Schools will only help Public
Schools uh can Public Schools uh
innovate without requested waivers sure
I imagine they can and I know they can
but are there going to be instances
where uh waivers stand in the way of
absolutely follow follow up Mr chairman
yes follow up representa Woodcock thank
you and and Rell I understand your your
belief of child schools being being the
Epic of innovation uh epicenter of
innovation and and suggesting not that's
fine I have no problem with that but I
don't understand how if the child
schools are so successful doing that why
we need to have an Innovative Public
School in the traditional public school
we have the option instead of making the
rule for the exception why not make it
for the general population I don't
understand that it's like just seems to
me like you're saying to public school
teachers and administrators we don't
think you're really very Innovative and
creative uh in your leadership and your
teaching um that that that that part
concerns me I think the opportunity is
there without going through this whole
bill um that's all thank you Mr chairman
question no that was just more of a
L thank you Mr chairman uh and thank
thank you uh representative cordelli um
before I proceed though I do want to uh
make a note that I am filing a
declaration of intent on this bill um
and that as the president of American
Federation of teachers New Hampshire um
but also has based upon the legislative
ethics committee's resolution of
complaint
2019-02 um I am hereby declaring my
intent to participate in regards to
hb29 um my question um is simply uh
actually I have two questions uh one is
um going back to this idea that you may
submit all these various and sunry
things as part of the Innovation plan um
if if we have the word may there and if
you leave certain things out if certain
things are not submitted does that
preclude them from ever being represent
LE yes sir I didn't I don't know if I
heard you correctly did you reference
209 or
609 for which the complaint
Declaration of int HB HB 609 HP 609 the
current bill good thank you we we heard
it sort of sound like 209 at this end
and oh I'm sorry
no9 gotcha go ahead you're welcome thank
you um so just on that listing of the uh
various things that could be that may be
included in the Innovation plan if
something is not listed in the
Innovation plan and The Innovation plan
is approved
D are any of the things that were
limits in terms of the May those are
spelling out some of the things that
might be included in an innovation plan
developed by the
school but is not uh saying that the
Innovation plan is wide open in terms of
um what they want to accomplish and uh
you know there could be things not
included in the in Innovation plan that
they want to actually do and specific
waivers uh the actual administrative
rule that they would request the waiver
from must be
specified followup please yes thank you
um does the Department of
Education have the
authority
to agree to
wave provisions of collective bargaining
agreements
because the plan is going to ultimately
Education uh I I do not believe so um
you can ask the department of uh
education uh attorney but I don't
believe so I think that would be uh
between the uh bargaining bargaining
unit and the uh District that signed the
agreement thank you can I may I ask one
more question Mr chairman
thank you um going to near the end of
the bill um if the uh Department this is
the Department of Education finds that
Innovation plan performance is not
satisfactory they shall notify the local
board in the State Board um what would
be the metrics that would be used by the
Department of Education to determine
whether the Innovation plan is meeting
um uh is is its performance is or is not
satisfactory I think that would go back
to the uh original plan and the uh uh
goals and mission of the plan what they
wanted to accomplish and if they weren't
accomplishing uh those goals the local
board can um pull the plug on the
Innovation plan and the state board can
uh revoke the plan as well thank you
thank you you're welcome uh representa
Tanner thank you Mr chair um I'm
concerned about the fiscal note um that
representative Woodcock kind of uh
brought up because whenever I see local
uh what pops into my mind is higher
property taxes um and I noticed there's
uh the LBA is not able to to complete a
fiscal note for this bill because it's a
waiting information from the Department
of
Education um and I know also all right
I took to heart your um theory that it
wasn't going to cost the schools uh the
local communities anything or the state
anybody here no hey uh represent
represent ten we're having a difficult
time hearing you can you speak either a
out we having a hard time hearing you uh
Linda is that better it's a little bit
better can folks here go ahead say
something okay I think my I think my
headphones are dying at this point uh
can you hear it or not
no no rep several Representatives you
the can you hear me now yes
yes that's better much
okay all right um
so uh what I'm concerned about is the
fiscal note at the endend whenever I see
local I always think of property taxes
going up and I realized that the LBA the
note on the end says the LBA is unable
to complete a fiscal note for this as
it's waiting awaiting information from
the Department of Education um I think
it would be really important in this day
and age to uh not make a decision on
this bill until we get a an idea of some
sort
what effect this has not only on the
state but more importantly on the local
taxpayer um and so uh I'm wondering if
you have any idea when that information
available uh that's if that's a question
it if that's a question to me I have not
talked to the department about uh um
you I I did speak with uh Caitlyn Davis
just yesterday regarding these fiscal
notes and and as you can well believe
that she's underwater trying to with her
staff uh she has some folks that an
individual came over from the LBA is
working with her now Mark is there
however she she's hopeful of getting
some of this out to as quickly as she
can I'm not going to try to give you any
it okay the next person that let's see
Linda you spoke and Doug this Doug are
you still got your hand
up okay uh how about you Mr Woodcock yes
one final question for me Mr
chairman representative cordelli uh
thank you for one more question here do
you know of
any public schools that have not allowed
to become
[Music]
Innovative um I have not taken a survey
of public schools in that regard um as I
said before I am sure there are
Innovations going on in New Hampshire
Public Schools I am trying to allow them
greater flexibility uh to
innovate thank you Mr chairman
thank you um I'm not seeing any more
hands remote and I don't see but we have
Caitlyn Davis that would like to get
back on so I'm gonna ask Caitlyn uh
could you please come on and maybe
explain to us a little bit about where
you stand with all these Financial notes
you're trying to
develop absolutely so um I think all of
the fiscal notes at least have been sent
over to the LBA at this point um so you
should be seeing those appearing um
specifically for this though um and um
Jen if you could uh promote Nate green
to speaker as well he's here to talk
about the educational aspects of this
bill if you have any specific questions
um for the fiscal note of this bill
though the the department did put that
it was Zero because there is no
requirement for this so you know the
point of a fiscal bill is if if there's
a new law that's passing that requires a
school district to do something like you
know provide a different addition
additional services or something like
that um that's when we would say there
is a cost but because it's not required
and it's optional it's there is no
specific cost relative to the bill for
local costs um we did um assign a cost
uh an indeterminable slash you know cost
of one position at the department
because you know in the first couple
years you know while a couple of these
are getting off the ground just like
Charter Schools we may not need a
specific position at the Department of
Education to oversee these schools
however if there are many or many many
of these schools that the department of
education does need to oversee um we
would need a full-time position just
like we have a full-time Charter School
administrator or a full-time non-public
school administrator um so that was our
cost that we had did ass sign for the
fiscal note but we did say that there
were no no local costs that were
required because it is not a required
that Local Schools do
this are there questions of okay
I see represent
Ellison uh thank you I it's actually for
the bill sponsor so I can I hold off on
that yes you may um are there any
specific questions for Caitlyn again or
she explained where we are with the
financial notes in the
Caitlyn
um oh there's okay we have another
individual from the Department that's
got on over there with her Christopher
Bond so um will you please hang on to
your question representative Ellison and
we'll hear from from
her thank
you yes hi this is Chris Bond thank you
um I did just want to respond to um one
question that I think uh representative
Lei had asked um about uh collective
bargaining agreements and I just wanted
to clarify that the department does not
believe it has the authority to wave
Provisions in colle ctive bargaining
agreements um nor do we read this
proposed legislation as purporting to
give that authority to either the
department or the board um the state
board that is um and then with that
comment I'm I just I'd be happy to uh
make myself available for any questions
if any anyone has any questions about
the Department's perspective although I
know Caitlyn has already spoken to the
fiscal
issues well thank you very much
Christopher I think that really nails
down that one where the department does
not have authority and that's between
the locals so
um uh thank you very much we're going to
go on some other questioning so we can
move on this a little
bit uh representa
Ellison uh thank you Mr chairman and
thank you representative cordelli for uh
taking my question I think I'm on page
three uh Roman numeral 5 C which talks
about provision of services included but
not limited to special education syst
Services as I read the introductory
paragraph at the the bottom of the page
before it says this an application for a
school may include references to a whole
lot of things I guess my question is is
specifically in C where it says limited
to it's not limited to special education
services could a uh an application for
an Innovative School decide that they
were not going to follow any federal
requirements in terms of special
education
services uh we are not in this bill
granting any waivers from Federal
Hanner
still huh can't hear me very weak very
week how about this that's a little
better okay um let me say uh how about
waivers of state laws on special
education and
anti-discrimination
no as I said in the introduction um some
states in their uh legislation for for
waivers of state law we do not just
administrative rules can be waved um in
this
questions representa Ellison is your
hand still up or did you take that I
will take it down thank you thank you
much
luno
thank you very much Mr chair uh just to
clarify um representative cordell's um
last statement waivers from
administrative rules only you would be
talking about waivers from
administrative rules that do not have a
correct administrative rules yes um
we're not know the bill does not provide
for um uh waving you know
193 um C12 pupil assessments for
instance there's no provision for doing
something like that right F follow up on
that Mr chair yes how however my
understanding from jelar is that
administrative rules have to have a
structural foundation in statute and
that the burden is on the department to
make that connection when Hello bringing
bringing rules before J
elar so so I guess what I'm what
I'm getting some somebody's voice I I am
I guess what I'm saying then is uh isn't
therefore an a waiver from an
administrative rule the same thing as
waving something that the legislature
and the governor intended to be in
case Okay um any further questions of
representa
cordelli we do have several other people
here in the queue who's up next
represent
Wards okay is there a Janet
number uh
Janet Ward I have 746 4991 I see Janet
j a member of the
public
if she's here okay can you bring her up
here
yes um good
afternoon
uh in May if I may share with you of
2018 a school voucher bill Senate Bill
193 was
killed now here we are in January of
2021 and a flurry of American
legislative exchange Council pattern
bills are coming through the the New
Hampshire
legislature all of these bills reflect
an anti-public School bias cloaked in
all kinds of language such as
Innovation which is meant to deflect and
deny anti-public School
bias House Bill
609 is one of these bills supposedly it
is meant to establish Innovation schools
but taxpayers like myself can reasonably
ask are Innovation schools necessary
given that we are already providing
support for many charter schools which
provide a variety of avenues for
Innovation and our state recently
accepted a Federal grant to establish
many more charter schools and to Second
what I've heard from committee members
public schools are Innovative I know
because I taught in them I was a
director of a gifted and talented
program the first one in hener New
Hampshire so I'm here to
say exciting things have happened for
years and are happening now Innovation
is happening in our schools so what is
House Bill 609 really seeking to
accomplish it's seeking to siphon
away more money from public schools and
to place it in the hands of those who
will establish programs
which will not be subject to rigorous
public scrutiny or regulation as with
school
vouchers my public tax dollars could
then be used by entities with seriously
limited public oversight Thomas
Jefferson was convinced that locally
controlled Public Schools were key
Democratic institutions and adlay
Stevenson remarked that and I quote the
free public school system is the most
American thing about America America
itself was and isair my second
question represent Huff sent a sent us a
letter which we want be in the permanent
record and just in the past has been
kind of hard to find these permanent
records but thanks certain C uh some
changes how we handle it
so to represent Huff or
somebody she
okay
ahead go
ahead my final
remark America itself was and is an
innovation if the framers of House Bill
609 want to see Innovation happen let it
happen
transparen transparently and with
taxpayer oversight in our public schools
and in our public charter schools thank
you for your time thank you Janet Ward
are there
questions not seeing any hands thank you
very much you're welcome the next uh
person we'd like to have speaking would
be uh baric Christina of the school
boards
Association thank you chairman lad um
thank you members of the committee
Barrett Christina executive director of
the New Hampshire school boards
Association um we did sign in opposed to
House Bill
609 um there are some things about it
that nhba likes we certainly like
representative cordell's idea of
lessening some of the regulatory burdens
um on school districts that may um serve
as an impediment to improving um student
outcomes or uh you know limiting um the
ability of districts to put into place
new programs um however um our concern
um with the bill and our primary
opposition um and I'll walk through some
of these things I think a lot of the
language would need to be to be cleaned
up first um if possible um for example
I'm on I'm on page one starting at line
14 um and 15 about a public school May
submit an application to the school
board it's not clear um who through in
the bill it's not clear who's submitting
that to the school board uh is it the
principal is it the teachers um and you
know also NH HSP certainly takes the
position that the the local school board
is in charge and responsible of all the
schools under its purview so something
like this is is being drafted or drawn
up um I I I just I'm not sure who it is
that's exactly submitting the
application to to the school board um or
or the or the Innovation plan you know
for example on same page on line 22 it
says that the school board ejects or
approves the plan the note to myself is
is who files the plan with the local
school
board um we had um some of the same
concerns that were brought up um I
forget which representative brought them
up about um uh using May instead of
shall um certainly the May provides some
flexibility and now I'm on just I'm
sorry to be clear now I'm on page two
line five um you know I I I I think that
some of the the the bullet points or the
paragraphs that follow the May were
intended to be suggestions or ideas but
not necessarily all
inclusive
um uh the the other concern nhba has on
page two line 12 this is paragraph C
that the plan has to include a listing
of uh Department of Education
administrative rules from which the
school district or the the Innovative
school is Seeking a waiver um as as
representative cordelli alluded to the
the the number of administrative rules
is is mindbending you know 20 plus P
it's just of a a table of contents uh
however we think that that provision
should probably be narrowed a little bit
rather than being a rather than allowing
such a school or such a plan to seek a
waiver of of potentially all the rules
and not saying that would happen the
language of the bill just says a listing
of any doe rules I think that should
probably be narrow to see exactly what
we're speaking about is it the minimum
standards under 306 is it um some of the
health standards I believe that's rule
um but some of the other department of
education rules such as
ed400 um which is the approval of school
buildings those are those are based on
fire codes for my understanding and
building codes so it would you know I
don't um you know I I don't think it
would be prudent to necessarily be able
to wave those certainly the um doe 1100
rules are are special education rules um
you know we'd want to be hesitant about
how if at all those might be able to be
waved by the department of educ
um moving on on page two um paragraph H
about the collective bargaining nhba did
not interpret this as meaning that the
department would have authority to to
wave provisions of a collective
bargaining agreement as nhba read that
provision um it's just a notification or
an indication within the plan that
certain that the collective bargaining
agreement may need to be modified in
order to modify that it's going to take
both parties to to collectively bargain
that and and and reach some sort of
mutual agreement before the the CBA
could be modified that that was NHS
sba's take on it
anyway um continuing on um page three
looks generally fine um I'm on page four
now this is lines 13 through about 16 um
where they're talking about the State
Board shall either approve or reject the
Innovation plan using reasonable
discretion um I think we need a higher
standard there than reasonable
discretion um I I don't have any
alternative language right now but it
seems that if we're talking about an
application to wave certain um rules um
from the Department of Education
especially if they related to things
like the minimum standards I think we
should have a higher standard for what
the um what the
um what the decision of the state board
would be based off of
um again especially if it related to to
ad adequacy or or School approval um
page four I'm on um line 24 this is
paragraph three it says no waiver shall
be granted from um any requirement of
the federal uh Essa every student
succeeds act um I think our our our
preference would be that no waiver shall
be granted from any federal requirements
I mean I don't think you could do that
anyway that a Department of the New
Hampshire Department of Education can't
simply wave a local school district's
obligation to follow a federal
requirement but just to be a little bit
more
all-encompassing um you know that would
ensure that um Provisions under special
education and idea law would would be
noted as being protected under the
bill um and I representative cordelli I
think you you did speak to this a little
bit and I'm on now I'm still on page
four um lines 35 and 36
um and it says if the local school board
finds that academic performance um uh
students enrolled in The Innovation plan
is not improving at a sufficient rate um
and you I believe representative Cordo
you talked about that based on sort of
being the goals that's that are
initially implemented um you know I
think that may make sense but again
there's going to have to be some sort of
metrics if you will um and more so not
so much at the local Schoolboard level
but if we turn to page five I'm on line
11 then this is paragraph 4 the State
Board May revoke the innovate The
Innovation status at any time with
notification of the local Schoolboard
and Department um I think that we would
have to put some criteria in the statute
as to what criteria the State Board is
going to be using um if and when it were
to revoke um uh in invitation status and
especially you know if it's been
approved through a process with some
sort of rigor and quality it seems to
make sense that it could be revoked or
withdrawn based on a similar um um
standard for lack of a better phrase um
so the relative to the bill itself there
are those were sort of nhs's concerns
with it um you know uh also as
representa of Cordo you mentioned I
believe there were 14 states that that
have these um uh have these the
legislation that allows for the
Innovative schools um I've done a little
bit of research on on those States um
not a lot yet but um given sort of the
the the widespread implication of this
bill we would think that um um you know
this committee um and I I apologize I
know there was some discussion earlier
about whether or not the legislature was
going to entertain committees or
commissions over the summer and the fall
and um regardless of that aspect um you
know it might be helpful for the
committee to get some more information
about the other 13 or 14 states that
have had this in place and sort of what
the outcomes are how their state board
of education if any has developed rules
relative to this um and whether or not
um you know these are leading to The
Innovation that that we that we would
hope for um and that we do have in our
Public Schools as well too um so last um
if you'll bear with me for one minute um
representative cordelli we certainly
appreciate the the the the idea of
Trying to minimize some of the
regulatory burden as I think I led my
comments off with that I guess NH sba's
last comment would be that if we feel we
I'm sorry I shouldn't include myself in
that if you feel that there is um uh too
much regulation at the Department of
Education and some of these regulatory
burdens are are impeding um uh things
that local school districts might want
to to try that are that are different or
new um the legislature has the authority
to pass statutes that either eliminate
or add to regulations so um if there's
too many regulations I think that's in
your hands and and and while I
understand this bill seeks to do this in
a limited fashion perhaps a a wider
review of of what doe regulations that
may be impeding school districts would
would be would be prudent as well too um
so uh with that uh those are on hba's uh
comments um I think the concept of of of
relaxing some regulations is a great
idea but the bill is written um we have
some some concerns with and with that
I'm happy to answer any questions from
the
committee thank you very much uh Barrett
we appreciate that input uh are there
any questions of the New Hampshire
Association
Erica you got it yes thank you Mr
repres representative Erica Leon from
der Rockingham 6 uh I see oversight from
four distinct entities the schools
School Board Department of Education and
the State Board of Education and all of
these are Tas with the regulatory
requirements that might be waved under
this bill these four regulatory arms are
vested in protecting the interest of and
outcomes in education in New Hampshire
and as written this bill allows for
innov for schools to test
out test out ways that perhaps we may
want to change the laws in the future
but without an opportunity to see if in
one microcosm this is beneficial or not
this it would be hard to put for some of
those new new regulations and new laws
or loosen them um there's a point of a
viw at 2 years so I I don't see how
allowing for different regulatory groups
to have checks and balances on these is
such a threat to the to the education of
our
children question oh I'm sorry yeah
everything has to be an inform of
question so okay I was writing it as qu
I was trying to put it as questions and
in my my experience in the past it
wasn't that I'm sorry so I guess what
I'm trying to ask you uh Mr Christina is
if if you don't if you believe that
these these four levels of regul uh
regulatory uh the schools school boards
Department of Education and State Board
of Education aren't interested in
keeping the majority of these
regulations
intact thank you for the question
representative um I I I had a little bit
of a hard time hearing you so I
apologize the clarification was are the
four levels of review sufficient to and
I missed the last part of that um to to
keep the interests of of keeping
regulations largely intact while while
trying while trying to provide some
flexibility to explore Alternatives sure
sure thank you for the question um
representative um I nhp's um concerns
with the bill were not necessarily
related to
the the three or four levels of
safeguards it's local school board the
department the State Board of Education
our primary concerns were with sort of
how the bill was written some of the
language in the bill that I think would
need to be cleared up and to your point
about um you know sort of the two-year
review or the two-year cycle that these
would be going through to have their
Innovative Innovation School status
renewed by the State Board of Education
um you know there's certainly you
know there's certainly
some precedent in the state for running
know pilot projects if you will um
before we just sort of opened up a a
full legislative um change without
necessarily understanding what the
outcomes might be which is why I
suggested there might be you might be
want to might make sense to establish a
a committee of some sort over the summer
and the fall to look at what the
educational outcomes um in Colorado but
I believe Colorado is the first state
and has been doing this for about 10 or
11 years or so um so you know maybe look
at the states that have been doing this
for five 6 10 years and see how their
local school districts are fairing
before
nhba um you know or excuse me before the
state of New Hampshire were to were to
move forward with something like
this thank you attorney Christina um uh
are there any further questions for the
school boards
Association
thank you very much Barrett and we
certainly appreciate your willingness to
work with us over the years on things
like manifest education
hardship thank you representative lad as
always nsba is here to assist the
committee as a whole or any individual
board uh committee members as as we
can okay thank you
um yes we we have did
uh dones uh Jim dones that's found
him Rhonda
Thomas okay is there a Rhonda Thomas
speak
needs to un uh Miss Thomas can you
unmute
please yes thank you first I want to
thank you guys for making this available
to parents to listen in so I'm grateful
for that I have a couple of thoughts
that I'd like to pass by um these
Innovative schools seem to be moving
away from the regular public school I
see them more as
um collecting bigger data on our
students they're going to be globally
connected which means uh sort of a no
borders look uh but more than anything
there's going to be larger data
collection on our students not only
social emotional learning but uh so
they're going to be so who who's who
looks at that who determines uh the
behavior of these students
and so you're going to be tracking them
uh I'm sure from beginning to end all
the way through into the business world
so I see these Innovative schools um as
being a replacement for the older way of
doing things and then I want to look at
who's making the money off of this I
would say uh one of those companies um
would be bright bites uh so that
concerns me as a parent are we going to
have access to these records of our
children and what happens to all this
big data and who ends up with it those
are my questions where does this big
data end up with our children and who
determines who's qualified to go on to
college and who isn't based on their
behavior and um you know this this is
huge you're really taking a lot into
your hands with our children and I see
it moving away from um
just basic good education I'm not
against technology but I'm against
collecting this big data so I want to
know who hands that data ends up with
who's making money off of it and how
does that affect our children thank you
thank you very much Miss Thomas uh are
there any questions that you would for
her was she going no I can bring it back
are there any questions from the
committee Rick Rick if I if I may add I
think as we get testimony from the
public uh for the record would it be
good for them to State their name and
the community with which they're coming
from yeah we can do that now thank you
you're welcome uh are I don't see
anybody with their hands up and she's
already uh Miss Thomas is already gone
so no I brought her back you brought her
back well sorry thank you for coming
back okay folks um I don't see anybody
else that signed up um there's a lot of
forms here which I received that are in
opposition to the bill I haven't
bothered to count them but one of these
sheets
um oh they they look like this and I got
like a number of sheets
so we had two more to speak from the
attendees okay okay we have two more on
the attendees from the public we'll have
these but these are going to be the last
two that we're going to have on this
particular bill would you please bring
Hobson
may it
okay
Sor that's Mr okay we have Jim Dodges
from nashwa that's the mayor would like
to speak on this one uh
welcome yes uh thank you Mr chair and I
know you're busy so I'll just take a
minute I want to speak in opposition to
the the bill that you have before you
for various reasons but principally
because it will reduce the level of
funding that is going to our public
schools at a time when we need more
money not less I mean we've been we're
almost one year into a pandemic now we
know that kids are suffer suffering a
learning loss in our public schools and
that Gap will have to be made up and to
do
that it will be more difficult to do
that if funds are cut and the mechanism
of funding The Innovation school would
be to uh take take money away from the
public school system now I've often
heard the argument that well if the
enrollment
declines you save money but that is not
really true if you think about
it I'm going to use Nash as an example
not because it's more important than any
other community but because I understand
you know the facts the
best the let's say we have about 350
classrooms and let's say we started an
innovation School
and 100 Kids joined now that's in 12
grades across 17 schools 350 classrooms
so maybe 100 classrooms see a decline of
one kid so in you know in the fourth
grade at ammer Street Elementary School
there aren't 21 kids now they're
but that doesn't decrease costs at all
but it does reduce Revenue to the the
school district because money school aid
is reduced and and directed towards the
Innovation
school one issue that you know problem
that has resulted from the charter
schools is
that the it they've they've caused a
loss in Revenue at a time when we can't
afford a loss in Revenue so in in the
interest of educational quality I and
and uh sustaining the public schools in
New Hampshire which are very obviously
very important I would ask that you
either defeat the bill or come up with
the money to uh replace any lost Revenue
that would go to that would that uh uh
school districts local school districts
would suffer as a result of the
establishment of a Innovation school and
the transfer of students to that school
I think that gives you know a summary of
my thoughts I don't want to take up too
much time I could do more but but uh
I'll leave it at that and take questions
thank you very much Mr Mayor um are
there
questions I see no hands thank you very
much for your input all right thank you
for having me hold it you got you got a
question from representative Moffet
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
mayor uh your question seems to imply
that an innovation school would be a new
different School my understanding is
that an innovation school would be the
same school that just uh gets a break
from having to follow some of the rules
uh is that not your understanding uh
well my understanding is that there
would be a separate School so-called
Innovation school like and kids would uh
go there just like they do in like for
example a charter
school uh again Charter Schools do offer
offer a you know a good route for some
kids kids but there's no question that
that they they C they result in a loss
of Revenue and therefore low a low lower
level of service at lower level of
schools follow
up I'd like to ask you follow up to the
sponsor if they could well no sponsor
sitting down now okay all right thank
you Mr Mayor we uh have a different view
of that thank you thank you very much Mr
Mayor thank you for having me yeah now
do we have one more
person
okay email oh is that Brian Hawkins I'm
not sure okay um yeah Brian is with the
Nea yeah can you hear me
Brian can you hear me Mr chairman yes I
can oh great thank you I'm not sure why
my um Zoom gets stuck on my email but
now you all have my email and so if you
have any questions for me afterwards I'm
happy to answer them via that um thank
you very much uh for the record Brian
Hawkins from Nea New Hampshire uh we
represent over
177,000 uh Educators across the state in
collective bargaining and
um so uh thank you thank you for taking
my uh testimony I'll submit some written
testimon that U Megan Tuttle our
president had uh to you but I'll just
sum up a couple points because I know
you're uh running short on time um the
first was uh regarding the involvement
of Educators in this uh bill um while
there are several Provisions in it that
uh call
for um public hearings um we think that
really in the spirit of developing an
innovation plan um uh just like in the
uh some of the tenants of Essa
stakeholders um really need to be
consulted and meaningfully participate
in these types of improvements and so we
don't see anywhere in this bill where
this uh specifically includes Educators
in that um so that's some that that is
an issue uh that that uh we have the
second has come up a few times it's the
collective bargaining issue and um you
know there are uh several lines in this
bill
uh including page two line 8 um and Page
Three line 24 where there's a series of
uh uh specific aspects around terms and
conditions of employment um that may be
submitted um to the state board for
approval uh we still have a concern
about that I know there's been a couple
of comments saying that um uh it's not
but on the uh when you get to the the
point in the bill where it talks about
approval or uh denial of the local uh
school board or the local public schools
plan it says that um it says that the
state board can approve or or deny that
plan and so what does that mean if a a a
school does choose to put in something
uh for example that that's up already
where it says a description of of any
uhu excuse me of any provision of
collective bar bargaining agreement in
effect for personnel that would need to
be waved or modified so um there are
there were the series of ma earlier in
the bill bill but at the end of it it it
does say a shall approve or deny and so
what does that mean for
um uh for Provisions such as that and
again some of which are uh Provisions
that specifically relate to uh
negotiating terms and conditions of
employment um we have a few other areas
of of concern around uh you know that
have been mentioned uh as well already
around special education um services for
English as a second language and so
forth but that's included in our our
written testimony so I I'll leave it
there I'll I'll just I'll emphasize
those two points about the educator
input and the collective bargaining
issue I'm happy to take any questions
thank you very much Mr Hawkins are there
any
questions not seeing any uh thank you
very much and we'll see you in the
hallways looking forward to it hopefully
someday not in the too distant future
okay thanks okay so that concludes uh
the people that are going to be giving
testimony to
609 I'm going to close this hearing and
I'm going to take a five minute recess
back you're doing a great job so's one
of the riggers here he's an attorney um
[Music]
and
I'm
keep
keeping
fig if they take the
[Music]
time
that
[Music]
it's
this I think
that has some re question I think you
did
[Music]
okay
ad
you
will you lead off on that one and then
I yes then I will off on the other one
ask
[Music]
19 and
go is there a copy over there on
the what one you looking for 393 is 393
in that pile over there HP
a
323 yes
323 323 and
[Music]
one
there you go Barb Rick Rick while while
we're waiting is it is I know it's
difficult but is it possible at the end
of the hearing for you to reiterate
those the numbers of who were opposed
and who were in support of the bill I
realize there's a lot going on here but
if you can remember to do that that
would be helpful um on the last bill
Barb sha s me said there's there's like
400 people that uh you know T didn't
testify but are opposed to the bill okay
and you heard the ones that you know
were testifying here that were in
support so I I apologize I had to run
out down to the
washroom no I know thank thank you
welcome well other than testimony those
presentation okay I'm going to open up
this uh last combined hearing for the
day what we've done is HB 194 and 323
are dealing with the same topic from but
they're both different so I'm G to have
the sponsor of
194 that is representative
cordelli speak and present on that
present that bill and you can ask him
questions uh and when he's done he'll
come he'll be then sitting here as chair
and I'll introduce uh
323 then if the public has questions on
either one they they can ask the
questions of
us uh see that's not going to work
either because you
first okay so I'm opening up the hearing
right now on hb1 194
uh this is a bill relative to the
release of student assessment
information and
data represent
cordelli thank you Mr
chairman uh for the record Glen cordelli
representing tuen B molon bur and
Region this has been a topic of
discussion um for the past couple of
years and the main goal is to to help
parents and districts uh helping
districts uh
involves making sure that information is
getting out on a timely basis to parents
uh with the results of State assessments
uh on their
children uh if that does not happen if
the results are not provided on a timely
basis districts are are in uh danger of
losing uh federal funds according to the
uh Essa every student succeeds Act and
the uh
idea uh so we want to prevent that uh
but there are districts we know and have
heard testimony about um that are not uh
getting information time out on a timely
basis and um on some occasions they're
not getting the information to parents
at all
uh so there has been um legislation
previously to try and address that and
we try and uh take it a step uh further
here
um our Statewide testing
agency has in their
contract that they can and will send out
the assessment data directly to parents
themselves they do that in
approximately a dozen other states
already uh I think that that would be a
a time saer uh both for the department
and for districts uh and ensuring that
parents get that information on a timely
basis as well as possibly more complete
information um including more
information uh related to student growth
which is part of the every student
succeeds
act so that's what we try and address in
194 uh especially in the first um first
paragraph
uh I I think that also um on lines 12
and 13 um I think in the last
legislation that was passed um there was
maybe uh
some uh maybe some better language that
we tried to incorporate here in terms of
uh I think the statutes now say that U
the
information um uh is kept um for 8 years
but there's no definition of when that
clock
starts um is it does it start with uh
their first state assessment or does it
start with your last state assessment so
we provide in here the language that um
the uh tested agency shall destroy the
student data uh when the student has
gone through the 8th grade when they are
U finished with the Statewide assessment
uh and now in high school they move on
to the SAT as the Statewide assessment
so there's no reason for the tesed
agency to keep the data longer than that
so the intent here is that uh the state
assessment excuse me the state uh
testing Authority um would be able to
send out uh the information um I know
that the uh Net bill uh takes a little
different um uh approach and um I think
we have a great
opportunity um while we have a
concurrent uh hearing uh for the first
time uh this year but I think we also
have the possibility to merge these two
bills um into one and uh accomplish
something that everybody can agree on
thank
you are there question questions for
representative cordelli representative
Miler uh thank you Mr chair there's no
question in my mind that the need for
parents to receive this data none
whatsoever but when we were dealing with
this last time representive cordelli we
raised the question with what is the
incident rate of school districts not
providing this information to parents we
asked the Department of Education to
give us a list of those uh those
delinquent school districts and we did
not receive any so my question to you is
do you have new
information that would basically talk
about the incident rate of parents not
fashion thank you for the question I do
not have um new information on any
specific U incident rate but uh I can
see if um we can get that information
please do thank you very
much further questions of represent
Mullen thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative cordelli um my concern
representative is in uh the second
paragraph which begins with 193
C12 uh in this paragraph the way I read
it the district shall provide student
address
information for the purpose of
Distributing uh
results but the department May provide
those results to parents or school I'm
not I'm not sure why the district is
going to provide
information and the department may or
may not request the entity to provide
the info to schools
uh I I believe uh that the uh Department
could send out the results through that
address or the excuse me keep trying to
say that the tested agency could send
out the results with that student
address but they're not excuse me a
followup Mr chair yes you may okay so
when I read this the department May
provide or may request the testing
entity to provide the assessment results
and comparative data to apparent illegal
guard
the people's schools it doesn't say that
the department shall provide or request
that the testing entity will provide or
shall provide it seems rather optional
with again with the use of the word may
that's I I I have that
concern I I will look at that thank you
you're
welcome uh represent Tanner then
represent of my
own okay I'm G to try it again can you
hear me yes okay my concern is the um
destroying the test testing data uh the
time limit uh set to um students through
8th grade or when a student is no longer
enrolled in the New Hampshire Public
School seems to me that they need to
retain that data for at least a year or
two in case there is some reason that
this student re leaves the school um
decides to come back uh there in this
day and age there's a lot of movement
back and forth and then the the data
isn't there so um I would strongly
suggest we at least put two years down
there what's your feeling on that um
thank you are you uh thinking of uh uh
the instance when uh they might leave
Yes I I see it up in our area a as well
as the beautiful lakes area I'm sure
we've seen an influx of people come in
with coid established residency here so
that their children can attend school
but I'm sure after cold snaps like we
just had they may be fast returning
subsides I if I might respond yes you I
would disagree that they they're still
going to
leave even with the co snap but uh
uh we have a lot of skar um so uh but I
will take uh your comment under
consideration about the uh leaving the
New Hampshire public school thank
you further questions of Representative
cordelli yes representative Miler thank
you Mr chair representative cordelli you
might not be able to answer this
question but one of the concerns I have
is that if this information is sent
directly to parents
parents it may uh it may impact school
districts who use this data as a
diagnostic
tool and I know some of the school
districts basically use this information
to diagnose exactly where students are
in their learning path and they talk
with parents about that my concern is is
that by directly sending it to parents
it may interrupt that process of using
it as a diagnostic tool in working with
parents in developing learning plans Etc
do you have any thoughts about how that
might interrupt that diagnostic
process did the school will still have
the result off as well um and I think
that parents getting the um uh data U
might spur them to contact the district
and and uh request a conference to uh
review the U the data with them and and
spur that diagnostic analysis that you
speak
of thank
questions not seeing any further
questions uh I will go ahead then seeing
that we're in a kind of a split session
here I'm going to start the second Bill
well first of all uh represent Hobson
are there any people wanting to talk
about that specific Bill not that I can
see okay so what we don't see anybody in
the you know waiting in the in the limbs
minute oh
yes okay we have one one person would
like to uh come on and testify Miss
okay am I live yes oh hi everyone okay
um this is all a new world so I thought
that I had um properly signed up to
testify virtually so apologies if I did
it incorrectly but it's nice to see you
all um hello chairman lad and represent
cordelli um wanted to to uh pop in and
just a little clarification was given in
repes of cordell's comments but we share
some concern around the same sentiment
as representative Tanner um and again
Ashley Gibson with the college board so
um we work closely with the state uh
being an
SAT um High School assessment State and
specifically around um the testing
entity shall destroy data after the
student is done in New Hampshire Public
Schools
um our concern lies within students who
request their scores after they're done
with high school for scholarship
purposes transferring institutions some
people don't go to their postsecondary
education right after high school and
then still request their college
entrance exam score so that's something
we want to put on your radar as a
concern um we don't want it to be um we
don't want it to be a barrier to a
student opportunity if they are done
with school at a New Hampshire Public
School have taken the sat in high school
or even on a Saturday um and then come
to us requesting their score for some
educational opportunity and and we have
to tell them that we in fact can't give
it to them because of the state statute
so um the the the overall intent of the
bill we are in support of but we don't
want any sort of unint intended
consequences um placing barriers to
student opportunities so wanted to come
and present that concern to the
committee um represent cordelli you have
an email in your inbox from me if you
haven't gotten to it already um because
I did receive feedback from our legal
and policy team about this over the
weekend so um I'm happy to take any
questions but that's simply Our concern
we don't want a student to not have
access to their score um for whatever
opportun they might want to take in the
future thank you very much for your
questions thank you very
much wait hold on a sec yes what do you
I just wanted to say that there were 11
people who signed in five support three
neutral on 194 okay uh apparently we're
seeing one more thank you very much for
your testimony here uh uh reference F
sat we have one more person uh for 194
white are these people just showing up
as we go over thank you this is Melissa
white I um work for the New Hampshire
Department of Education I am the
administrator for assessment and I just
wanted to make myself available for any
questions regarding the assessment
system and just to clarify uh a couple
of things about our assessment system if
that is
okay go ahead so our New Hampshire
assessment system consists of several
assessment systems sat you just heard
about for our 11th grade students for
ELA and Mathematics we have our New
Hampshire SAS or
nhas which assesses our students in ela
and Mathematics from 3D through 8th
grade are NH SAS also assesses our
students in science in grades 5 8 and 11
we also have our Dynamic learning Maps
assessment and that's our alternate
assessment for our severely disabled
students that um the New Hampshire SAS
test is not appropriate for and they
would take that test in ela Math and
Science from grades three through 8 and
also 11th our final assessment uh
assessment that's part of our assessment
system is our access test which is the
requ ired assessment our English
language Learners take to um look at
their English language proficiency our
students take that from kindergarten all
the way until 12th grade and so I just
want to make it clear that it's not just
past 8th grade that we would need that
data for some of our students we would
actually need that data from
kindergarten all the way through 12th
grade and that's just the ability to
make sure that we're supporting them and
providing um the services that they need
and the school's ability to be able to
keep keep that data and so when we're
looking at an assessment system it's it
goes um just beyond third through 8th
grade or just beyond eth grade we we are
looking at kindergarten through 12th
grade thank
you thank
you thank you very much uh we will go
ahead now and go straight into the other
Bill uh HB
323 uh at this point in time I'll turn
the gavl over to representative
cordelli uh thank you Mr chairman uh
this time I would like to open the he on
House Bill
323 which
is similar title uh coincidentally
relative to a Statewide student
assessment report thank you thank you
very much representa cordelli and
members of the committee for the record
my name is Rick lad I come from hail
Grafton 4 um yes we just heard from the
Department uh about the state Assessment
program um we are specifically looking
at in this bill the Statewide assessment
which is required by Essa and that is
grades three through eight a separate
test then what you see at we're required
to do it in one grade in the high school
level we opt for grade 11 and that is
the SAT in this state we also have the
option if so desired to use the ACT but
we're using sat so uh my my concerns are
that this is a a mandated test by the
federal government and this bill
requires schools to produce and provide
to parents teachers and principles an
annual assessment report by June 30th of
each year the every student succeeds act
along with the Federal Regulations
requires that results from the annual
academic assessment given each spring be
quote provided to parents and teachers
as soon as practicable poss practically
possible after the test is taken in an
understandable and uniform format and to
the extent practicable provided in a
language that the parents can understand
that is from Federal Regulation so we
have to have that provided to parents it
has been communicated to the committee
in the past
and I have again learned just the other
day when I was at thee that it still
continues that in some school situations
and I'm not going to mention the
specific schools test results are not
provided to parents until the start of
the next school year the next school
calendar this is certainly not a timely
process and does not provide a parent of
a child who needs academic assistance
the summer months for needed remediation
or or Improvement so they don't
understand or they're not receiving the
information till later on in fall in
some kind cases this bill was developed
for the purpose of ensuring that parents
would receive testing results in a
timely and informative manner receiving
test information four months after
taking the assessment as I see it is
just not
acceptable the Statewide assessment test
is an achievement test which identifies
growth and from that
test children are seen as level one
level two level three or level four
level three is proficient level four is
you're highly proficient level one and
two two is where you're slightly below
and one you're you're you need a lot of
help and we use this in many cases when
we're directing funds to schools to
identify grade levels or levels of
achievement these students are in so
it's my concern that this data is
available to schools quickly soon after
the test is taken it's computerized now
so it is available but we're not getting
it out in a timely
manner so there may be a lot of
individual Co causes in schools but
really it does result in unintended
consequences when parents cannot offer
our uh offer our
make available to the students that
needed support that is necessary to keep
them on track for the next school year
this is going to be very important after
what we've going through this year when
students haven't had the opportunity to
be in classrooms the way they were in
quote normal sessions and parents are
anxious to find out what uh how their
students are progressing I'm not laying
blame on anybody I understand this is
coid and you know I have have uh three
days a week I've got middle school kids
in my family right there in the house
and I have become the teacher and it's
you know it's it's quite frankly I just
you know really put all teachers on a
Podium a pedestal they do a wonderful
job and I recognize how difficult that
chore is that profession I've been a
teacher myself so in conclusion this
bill simply states that the 30th of June
is when those test have to be results
have to be out by the commissioner has
the option to Grant an exception based
upon some some situation and that's
written commissioner May Grant an
exception to the June 30 deadline so in
conclusion this bill is set up so that
we can get parents the information they
need in a timely manner thank you very
much thank you I see a few hands up
there uh representative luno thank you
very much uh Mr chair and thank you very
much um representative lad for U for
introducing the bill now uh as you know
uh having served on the um on the uh
school funding commission uh one of the
things that we learned um during that um
um 11 months of work was the strong
correlation between student outcomes and
poverty and in particular poverty as as
calculated by um uh
uh the number of students in a in a
district that enroll in the free and
reduced price lunch program so so
looking at uh at that report and the
findings in that report there was very
that that correlation existed exists I
mean and um
and in developing that correlation or in
determining that correlation uh uh uh
much time was was spent to understand
how districts how students in districts
uh perform and so uh so my question uh
really goes to this bill how is this
going to um going to help let's say the
13,000 kids in um in Manchester the
Manchester School District that on
average
underperform U State averages by two
standard
deviations which um let me just put that
in relative terms if State average is
the 50th percentile two standard
deviations is about the second
percentile um so um so just wondering
how this is going to help those
kids um to start with uh in 2018 when I
was on the ugger study there that looked
that task force and Mel Meer you are on
that as well um I did a a look back at
achievement tests for a number of years
I produced a sheet based upon smarter
balance and some of the preceding
achievement tests that we've used and
using the equalized property valuation
per pupil is what we used and it's
similar to what you're speaking to we
found that in the bottom
quartile of those districts with low
equalized property valuation there was a
very high percentage of students with
which were in the lower levels of
achievement level one in mathematics and
and language arts reading as well uh and
level two as you went up to the top
quartile as far as when you're getting
now close to you know well over a
million dollars equalized property
valuation per pupil the it started
reversing in fact it was reversed it was
almost like totally opposite each other
from end to end so we do know that in
this districts where there is a low
level of uh property value which pretty
much correlates to what we talked about
what represent Luna talked about in the
free reduced meals as well um those are
the students which we need to really
support but in order to really support
these students it can't come just from
the school it also has to come from the
family and the achievement test is
developed to show growth we used to only
get use that achievement
score and and still and we used to say
to a family or to a student you're still
down around under the bar maybe at the
30th percentile
level but they may have been the year
before that at the 20th percentile level
so what we want to key in on is these
students are learning they're growing
there's growth shown and that's what we
got to convey but we got to convey that
to the parent um as as quickly as
possible so that they also can be a
partner in education and be working at
home with the student and working on
areas that we we we see as needing that
growth the achievement tests we're
giving are really not diagnostic tests
their test to show overall achievement
and a broad range of skills and
knowledge so that if we can convey that
as quickly as possible to parents they
become Partners in where we're going and
I believe through a process of doing
this quickly and in a timely manner that
partnership grows and and I I know that
right now I wish I had some of that with
the kids going to school just two days a
week and the kids come home oh I doing
well but the homework's not getting done
and and so there communication is a key
these tests are a key and and one
component and to make a long story short
we need to have better Communications
with the other part of the story that's
the parent which is responsible for
educating that child as
well follow up Mr chair real
quick yes so thanks very much Mr chair
and and representative lad I largely
agree with with with what you um uh were
just saying uh with the exception a
couple of exceptions that there's a
significant difference between uh
equalized property value per pupil and
uh and poverty in a district so um so
I'll give you an example ex Le the um
the the town that the that that that um
representative cordelli represents has
um has a very very high equalized
valuation per pupil but there are
certainly pockets of poverty and there
are certainly families that are
impoverished that um that also live in
that community and that's something that
we see around the entire state that
situation is is exacerbated in our more
um U urban areas such as is Manchester
and nashaa which actually have the
highest incidence of um of of poverty in
the state so getting back to the point
you were making representative lad which
is very good that improved communication
between the school district and the and
the students and families is really
important in order to help those
students raise their their performance
levels I I guess it's it's it's it's not
striking me how that's being done um in
an effective manner with with a letter
coming from either directly from the
Department or from the uh from the from
the test agency to the um uh to the
student but uh but I think what we heard
last session on this bill was that uh
was that it had been done in a much more
and I'll just use the term caring
approach uh you with um with u Council
staff at uh at the student school and um
to try to provide the um the the tools
uh for those families to um um uh to
improve the students
performance I'd like to respond to that
uh represent luno um I understand that
have places like Lincoln where the
property values are high and you have
large Pro pockets of poverty where um uh
the locals live and uh and so there are
differences between equalized property
value for pupil and the number of kids
which are for example in Title One Part
4 b um so um but I I I getting to the
last part of what you were stating
the the need to get this information to
the parent prior to everybody closing
shop at the school walking out the door
and going home for this the summer break
is important the if the parent has that
information
by the close of school the parent then
has the opportunity to go to school talk
with the teacher while the teacher is
still there and say okay I want to work
with my child what do you recommend Mr
or Mrs teacher and how can I move
forward to help my child in this
mathematics so there is no excuse for a
school to be holding on to this
information and saying well we'll just
get it out when the secretaries come
back to the office here or etc etc all
my years as a school principal and
Elementary School principal we got this
information back in a timely manner and
as soon as it hit the the school it was
out to the parents and we had parent
conferences before we closed shop we
were and that's how you get a school to
go from level one to two to three is
that so I'll I'll leave it at that thank
you
thank you very much M representative
vad thank you representative
Woodcock thank you Mr chairman uh
represent lad thank you for your
comments I want to just bring back some
history and then a question if I may
last year when we heard this bill
similarly um the some of the School
departments that were present to testify
uh in that other world of testifying uh
indicated their concern was that they
didn't have a chance to provide students
support they needed when theyed when the
student left at June 20th 26 they didn't
have program then and they they thought
at least the the school administrators
were presenting that they were much
better off starting with September uh
with the information and providing
remedial instruction helping them then I
mean that was the pitch last year that
they presented I understand you're June
theth piece uh but I I I think the way
the bill is constructed now uh with just
June 30th and and uh I mean you can even
mail it out by June 30th the schools are
gone forget the remote I mean a real
terms the school are already closed for
the summer anyhow but when you have
youngsters who are uh
significantly uh subpar with their
performance or or success level and we
tell parents here's here's where your
youngsters not achieving have a happy
summer and we have you know it's really
difficult if this was bridged with a
requirement to provide programming in
the summer for these youngsters or those
things that would make a lot lot more
sense this just seems to me that we're
giving them a uh people who are already
floundering uh no even life Lifeboat and
it's going to be further Amplified this
year we see the learning loss because of
remote learning so it's going to be I
think I think there's a lot of issues
here Beyond just the simple simplified
June 30th giving the information we're
just putting them out there students who
have been successful when we look at the
the scores and we look at the income
levels as well we know that those pizza
kids are g a much better chance so we're
taking the the students who have the
most difficult opportunity to start with
and making it more difficult so I I just
think there's a lot of things represent
glad about this bill that that are um
unintended and could be further improved
to make it a great Bill uh than it sits
right now so just curious about your
thinking about making a a bridge bill
with help in just a notice of I'm sorry
thank you Mr chair there is a question
actually yeah I I didn't get the
question in there at all Mr Woodcock but
uh um it sounds like another principal
uh I I feel very strongly that I'd like
to work with you or work with anybody so
that we can recognize that we can come
up with all the reasons for not
communicating early to parents and that
is part of our problem as Educators I'm
putting myself in that that bag too I'm
an
educator but it it's it's important that
we recognize the importance of the
parent and if we have this information
Back
available this is the way we're going to
show achievement and growth um if the
teacher that's got the kids for this
fiscal year and and in the fourth grade
has sees something going on there's a
recommendation for summer reading you
might want to do this you might want to
go to your Public Library and get some
assistance and that's all available uh
it's it's a shame that we oftentimes get
this data back in the fall or you know
the parent does and and it's not looked
at by many staff members in the school
because they're so busy trying to close
down but the test scores can get mailed
out if you wait to give it out in the
the second third fourth fifth weeks of
the school year coming or as late as
October that's old
stuff um it's it's not current it's now
how many four months old um I just don't
get it and I I know that after talking
with the Department of Education the
test results are available in the
spring and for folks out in the field
say we can't get it out that early um I
you thank you uh next is representative
Tanner I
believe thank you um it's been a number
of years since I've been in the
classroom but I remember distinctly
having four separate grading
periods uh having within those grading
periods halfway uh a report that went
home this was at the high school level a
report that went home if a student was
uh not performing up to their potential
and uh getting a you know a d or a c
minus uh um so by the time the end of
the school year arrives uh the parents
have had eight different um
opportunities to see the what the
student is actually doing in school uh
what you're talking about is the high
stakes testing that drives so many
people crazy both in the schools and
without the schools outside the schools
um to the point
where uh it's not a good measure in most
uh instances of what's been going on in
the school or or for a lot of students
what they're actually doing and it's
hard for parents to understand that so
my question to you is um do you expect
that the parents will thoroughly
understand all the all the um test
results that come through from these
high-stake testing and will actually
make an opportunity to get in touch with
the school in the fall um to see how
things could be better or even in the
spring if they get the testing results
in the spring do you think parents I
mean do you think parents really
understand what the test results
indicate and if they indicate completely
different than what's been going on in
the school during the whole year with
all these reports going
home represent Tanner I I don't think a
parent going to understand terms like
standard deviation I could sit down
explain it to them that's not in their
ball game how however they are aware
that these achievement scores
demonstrate growth um I and and I also
believe that we've been sending this
information home for our students in
grades three through eight for
years and parents get that and there's
also a little component on the slip that
comes it shows you the strengths and the
weaknesses and some of the things which
are occurring um in terms of that
achievement score uh a parent that looks
at that and yes some parents won't look
at it but the majority will the majority
will and when I as a parent would see
something like that I would be quick to
contact the school and say okay what can
I do where are we going how can we work
work together to resolve this problem um
again I think we can find out all the
excuses for not doing this and I I
believe that parents are educated
parents and parents are able to
understand what we're sending home and
if they don't understand it it's up to
the school prior to them sending this
stuff home to make sure there's an
opportunity to have parents come to
school and explain the nature of what
our testing program is all about thank
you thank you next we have
representative
Mullen thank you Mr acting chair and
thank you representative lad for taking
taking my uh comments and questions to
heart um there's actually something in
this bill representative lad that I love
and that is the line that says the
report shall be provided to parents in
an informative and instructional manner
to help children meet challenging State
academic standards standards and
advanced student learning I love that I
love that line um my concern and I'm
wondering if you have given any thought
to this is for the school districts that
testified last year that told us that uh
the window of testing for some of them
uh backed right up into the third week
in
May and that they used those test
results that came back as part of their
professional development over the summer
to design remediation and stepped
programs for kids who needed additional
support
and also that that in the case of a
couple school districts we heard from
people that said that they actually
scheduled the parent conference at the
beginning of the school year with the
you know the fourth grade teacher met
with the kids that were going off to
fifth grade's parents in the
fall um so my concern is um that you
know we're giving detention to the whole
class when five kids have
misbehaved I'm worried that
um there may in fact as you said there
may be a handful of school districts out
there that aren't doing what they're
supposed to do but um I I I I'm just
wondering if you are being cautious
enough in thinking about those school
districts that are not only doing it the
way they're supposed to but are doing an
exemplary job but don't meet the June
30th
deadline that make sense I I appreciate
your comments regarding the the window
for testing and I'm going to get that
information for us and find out you how
that's impacting us uh I also support
the professional development that's
needed and the ongoing instruction based
upon what we're seeing in growth in the
in the year to come um without a
date like June
30th um it will defin the distribution
will slide into the fall for sure and
we're missing an opportunity
and we've seen what's happened in school
districts where for these extended
periods of time and we're in it right
now with coid how there will be a less
of a learning curve going up than there
would be in any normal season when the
kids are at
school and I think uh I'd like to see us
work to try to get this together I do
know that when I me mentioned it before
to the to the committee that when I
chaired the commission for
infrastructure funding that was $30
million we had districts that never sent
in an emergency management plan to doe
or on to the Department of Safety when
Perry plumber was director over there
and he had people digitizing these plans
at safety they came wanting a grant for
the infrastructure for security in the
schools Windows Doors you know systems
cameras Etc and we looked right at them
and said you're not going to be eligible
to receive anything until your Grant or
your uh plan is in here within two weeks
we had all those plans into the
committee so there's a
tendency uh on the part of some school
districts because there's so many
reports due I got that I got it that
things are put on somebody's desk and
they're not done on a timely
manner but line is it's about the
students it's about the growth of kids
and that's what this is Bill is about so
I'll work to try and get the information
on the window for testing and and if
there I know there schools I've been
told there schools are not doing this um
I don't want to get into the business
and names I I know them uh and I don't
think it's fair to be saying something
without you know that it shouldn't be
done right here so uh I'd like to work
with you uh representative Mullen uh I
do like that last sentence very much
myself um it's it's critical so thank
you very
much okay I do not see any other
Representatives with questions but I do
see uh the um representative from uh the
Department of Education Melissa white
up yeah go ahead Melissa I know she was
coming great thank you um I just wanted
to make myself a available to answer any
questions about the assessment system or
the uh student uh reports that are
available for parents um just to clarify
for the New Hampshire SAS our testing
window usually begins in the middle of
March and it goes all the way until
about the middle of June so for this
year for example I believe it begins
March 8th and will end June 11th this
report that is available for parents
it's a parent uh we call it an
individual student report it's a report
that is created specifically for parents
in a language that they can understand
using terms that they can understand
this report is immediately generated
once the student finishes the assessment
so the moment the student finishes their
assessment for math their score is
generated when they finish their
assessment for ELA it's generated and
then this one report will include their
um scores for Math and for ELA and if
they have taken a previous assessment
perhaps in another a previous grade
level it'll also include the growth from
that specific test until the one they
have just taken so with the test uh re
reports being available the moment the
student finishes the assessment so for
example if they finished it let's say
March 30th it's going to be available
March 30th and can be sent to parents
the moment that it's finished that it's
generated in a PDF form so it can be
emailed to parents or it could be
printed out and also sent home with a
student or could be sent home um by the
school but the anybody in the district
that has access to that report for
students it could be a test coordinator
a test administrator a teacher a
principal they all have access in the
ability to provide those individual
reports to parents the SAT is a little
bit different in that it the um tests
usually happen March and April and then
the scores are available definitely
before June 30th but they're not
available the moment the student
finishes the test so just to clarify
that with the New Hampshire SAS for ELA
math and science that score is
immediately available when the student
finishes Mr chair yes represent Miler a
question uh Miss White is there a uh is
there a portal with which the parent can
also get this information is it put into
a parental portal so at this time we do
not have a specific Parent Portal that's
available that but that we are working
on developing that with our uh cambam
assessments which is our vendor for our
assessment system so that at that point
parents would just have the ability to
Pro you know give the school permission
the school can provide an and an email
for that student and then uh it can
immediately be sent but at this time we
don't have the parent portal option but
we are working on making that available
as soon as possible as as a followup Mr
chair go ahead I'm I'm now chairing I
know okay the the I I don't mean to go
back to 194 that we looked at before but
is there is there a way with which uh
Miss White that the department is
contemplating Gathering the names of
parents Etc so that this could be sent
out
immediately so at this time we don't
have the ability to gather up the names
the and we have you know have parents
request that we don't have that ability
to do that internally no but with the
development of this Parent Portal
through our our assessment system then
you know we'd be able to you know just
provide that to parents and they could
access it but at this time we don't have
that capability because one of the
issues that this committee has dealt
with on an ongoing basis the whole issue
of security and names Etc and so that
would be one of the concerns I think 194
would have to address too so thank you
very
much are there any other questions uh or
speaker can I also askes Mullen go ahead
uh so representative lad just as a
followup to your testimony while Melissa
is still here um what happens what
happens to a school that doesn't get
their reports out by June 30 like who's
going to track that information how are
you going to know who didn't get the
reports out and and what's the what's
the
consequence you want to share it right
now while I
so oh no no okay would you like take
yeah I'll take the question from Ron
Mullen
um
the there really isn't a way to catch
this right now it's we hear about this
when the parents saying I just didn't
didn't get anything
um you H something that we all all have
to be thinking about
accountability and oversight on all
these programs we have this the doe is
really limited with staff when you have
just one individual maybe in testing and
and couple people in finance we're
shallow and so I I think what the the
oversight really has to come from the
district um we have leadership in the
district uh we have principles in the
district um and I think that leadership
and best practice this has to come from
the local level I I don't think we need
to say to apartment you have another
another deal you got to you know take
care
representative
Corell I think Melissa said that the
testing window in some districts went
right through the middle of June so
that would if there are a number of
those schools or districts where they're
still testing in June they won't get
their test results back before the end
out
that's may I please clarify yeah so if
the end of the testing window the window
ends June 11th if the student takes that
test on June 11th their score is
generated June 11th so the teacher or
test administrator has the ability to
11th
okay are we are done the questions me
can I take over
again for whom last
Lady okay we we have representative leus
would like to talk to Melissa about the
uh Melissa white are you still there yes
sir okay we have a representative on the
committee uh Alicia like us would like
to ask you a
question thank you for taking my
question um I'm just trying to
understand so when the test is done the
results are there what then is happening
at this point between the results are
there the school having the results and
the parents are having results what what
is actually happening and what is
causing the delay
I'm not sure um what that might be on
the school end but you know I myself uh
was recently a classroom teacher and so
I would have that report I could look at
that report I could save it as a PDF and
immediately email it to a
parent the moment this that the student
has finished the
assessment thank you if if I chose to
print it out I could just print it out
and then send it home with the student
as
well so you could
do so you could do that the very same
day that the test was done you as a
you are there F further
questions I see a hand up in the
Oliver
can you tell what's going on Deb still
muted it looks like you're still muted
uh representative
Ford okay now go good thank you uh thank
you for taking my question many of us in
this conversation have been in the
classroom some of us at various levels
and we've also been administrators what
concerns me about this is that we're
asking for
information that is basically put on a
shelf and not used and we're all aware
of how kids are losing uh progress
achievement over the coid problem of
just that kind of delay and then I hear
talking us talking about we've got to
get the information and we don't act on
it until next September and I'm thinking
as I hear that why are we doing that why
don't we link perhaps some of the remedy
to getting the information and tie it
closer together and look at this as a
two-step thing rather than a one-step
thing and just think about it because we
know that most kids learn to read within
certain age groups they learn to do math
within certain certain other age groups
this is something we all know then why
not say do a concentration on reading in
the summer or on math in the summer and
Link that to these data that we get and
work toward the solution so that when
they come back in September they haven't
slid backwards they've moved
ahead so I'm just thinking that maybe
well I I can I can respond and it's you
know just not uh as chairman now I'm
away from that bill but I think that um
you're talking about a parent also
assisting and teaching too and I concur
we're all in this together and you have
these opportunities you let two or three
months pass you're letting you know a
quarter of the year pass you by and in
term terms of the lifespan of a student
in
school we can't afford to do
that so I I I I I think this this bill
has a lot of wonderful merits in it
we're just going to have to work to try
and figure out how to get it the way we
feel we should I appreciate Melissa
White's comments and information um
Melissa do you have anything else to
offer us right
now um no I don't think so but I'm
available for any questions thank you so
I think what we're going to do is now go
on to other presenter because we one
presenter left and then we're done with
this bill uh we're done for the day so
um who do we have on the I think we're
all done oh we're all done we're all
done then so um if there's no more
questions and I don't see any
hands good and no hands here either so
I'm going to close the hearing for 194
and
323 and call it a day here we are now um
done our docket uh some words of advice
for everybody set aside Tuesday and
Thursday of next week and of the
following week the calendar will be out
uh we have to get all that scheduled the
calendars are released uh information
has to be in by 1 o'clock on Wednesday
and they should be out to you all
sometime on on hopefully thereafter
Thursday I'm not going to guarantee um
but that's the clerk's office business
so um are there any comments now uh it's
opportunity for some feedback from those
that are online or or from the room
right
here I just want to tell okay we have
okay uh uh representa Woodcock just a
quick one representa lad thank you um is
being home on Zoom depending on who is
speaking uh in the L some we heard very
clearly and some faded away represent C
was a great example at some point I
don't know if he moved he closer to the
mic whatever it was he came through loud
and clear but when he's starting his
opening and stuff was really really hear
it so I don't know if that's a tech
technical piece down there up here just
just the
FYI just if I could the the microphones
are actually on tables in front of
us um so you know I guess sit up as
close as we can um in our desk area um
but that's where the microphones are so
they're good six feet from
us when we started today earlier um we
started a little bit late because we had
for folks from uh technical side
computers coming in here and juggling
these mics around moving them around and
so um perhaps what we'll do next time is
we'll make sure we're in here early turn
this system on and try to see if we can
you know zoom in from another location
to building if things are clear and can
be heard um but I think for our first
time we were we got to our bills and um
I appreciate everybody's sitting tight I
envy some of you at home where you can
go raid the refrigerator when you want
to um here there's
nothing I need a ref refrigerator behind
me for my coffee milk so um thank you
all very much and I appreciate your your
hard work if you have any feedback
please send me an email and I I I'll
I'll listen I have one more thing one
more from the clerk um representative
Mel uh 411 people on a house bill
609 and five uh
alrighty so thank you very much and is
there a motion to adjourn so moved
second and we got a motion made and uh a
second to a journ made by represent
cordelli and represent uh Hobson uh just
show your hands and we're out of
here thank you very much have a good
evening